RECONVENE A BUDGET SUB ONE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
TODAY IS TUESDAY MARCH
FOURTEENTH AND WE ARE NOW IN THE
PM.
WOULD THE PANELISTS FOR ISSUE
NUMBER TEN PLEASE STEP FORWARD
.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GREAT SO GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER
CAN'T DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- SO. FOR ISSUE TEN
WE'RE SEEKING -- AUGMENTATION
AND REAPPROPRIATION OF FUNDING
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR -- CAME
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT --
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM
THAT WE OPERATE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ADMINISTERS -- ARE FEE
FOR SERVICE -- CHECK RIGHT -- ON
A WEEKLY BASIS AND SO THERE'S A
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
COMPLEXITY IN THAT SYSTEM IN
TERMS OF THE INPUTS COMING IN
FROM PROVIDERS BILLING US FOR
CLAIMS AS WELL AS US PUTTING OUT.
CHECKS WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
MODERNIZING THAT ANTIQUATED
SYSTEM AND SO THERE ARE TWO
REQUESTS IN FRONT OF THE
LEGISLATURE -- FOR PURPOSES OF
THE MAY REVISION AND THAT WE ARE
SEEKING -- REAPPROPRIATION
LANGUAGE FOR FUNDS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN EXPENDED -- IN THE CURRENT
YEAR BUT WILL BE NEEDED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR A
TOTAL OF FORTY SEVEN POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS -- FOR OUR
TURNOVER AND TAKE OVER COSTS SO
WE DID A PROCUREMENT -- MAYBE
ABOUT A YEAR AGO AND WE SPLIT
THE CONTRACT BETWEEN AN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
VENDOR AS WELL AS A BUSINESS
OPERATIONS UNDER THE TURNOVER
AND TAKE OVER FROM OUR PREVIOUS
VENDOR INTO THOSE TWO NEW
CONTRACTS WITH TWO NEW VENDORS.
IS SOME OF THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT AS WELL AS THERE ARE
POSITIONS IN THIS REQUEST -- FOR
WHAT WE WOULD CALL -- OVERSIGHT
TO OWNERSHIP -- SO AS PART OF
STATE -- TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS
WHAT WE ARE TRYING VERY MUCH TO
DO IS TO CREATE BOTH THE
EXPERTISE THE KNOWLEDGE.
AND THE CAPACITY WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT -- TO BOTH MONITOR
AND ADMINISTER -- SIGNIFICANT IT
PROJECTS RATHER THAN RELYING ON
VENDOR SOLELY TO DO THAT ON OUR
BEHALF AND SO SOME OF THE
POSITIONS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
YOU FOR THE MAY REVISION ARE --
DEDICATED TO CONTINUING THAT
EFFORT TO DO THAT -- PARTICULAR
STAFF EXPERTISE AND CAPACITY
BUILDING.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
BROWN WAS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE ARE
REVIEWING THISPROPOSAL AND HAD
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT -- THE
INCREASE IN THE COST RELATIVE TO
AND THE LAST PCP HERE IN.
AND THESE QUESTIONS ARE ARE
REFLECTED IN THE AGENDA -- AND
AND ARE ARE WAITING FOR A
RESPONSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT ON
THOSE ISSUES.
NEXT WITNESS.
UP CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WE BELIEVE THE MODERNIZING
CAMPUS IS A PRUDENT MEASURE BY
THE DEPARTMENT AND WE CAN DEFER
TO THE DEPARTMENT ON THOUGH IS
QUESTIONS.
AND I THINK WE'RE WORKING ON
FURTHER MORE DETAILED WRITTEN
ANSWERS TO ELLIE -- BECAUSE THEY
HAVE CERTAINLY ASKED FOR
QUESTIONS.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SEEING NONE I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
THAT CONCLUDES.
ISSUE NUMBER TâM.
WE WILL TAKE NO ACTION AT THIS
TIME TO ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
ISSUE.
ELEVEN YES SO THIS IS -- A
BUDGET -- STAFFING REQUEST I'M
SPECIFICALLY IN OUR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER COMPLIANCE DIVISION
FOR SEVEN PERMANENT POSITIONS
AND EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
APPROXIMATELY MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM OUR LICENSING FUND -- THIS
IS A COMBINATION I REQUEST FOR
MULTIPLE WORKLOADS WITH IN THAT
DIVISION SO -- AS PART OF ANY
KIND OF EMERGENCY DECLARATION SO
LAST YEAR FOR THE WOLSELEY FIRES --
FOR EXAMPLE -- WE HAVE STAFF
THAT WERE CALLING HUNDREDS OF
FACILITIES DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAD EITHER BEEN
EVACUATED OR HAD -- BEEN LOST TO
THE FIRE BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RESIDENTS HAVE
BEEN EVACUATEDWHAT THEIR STATUS
IS IF THEY HAVE OPEN BEDS.
SO SOME OF THE STAFF ARE FOR
THAT KIND OF UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THAT KIND OF CONTINUING ONGOING
WORKLOAD.
AS WELL AS THERE ARE STAFF IN
HERE FOR THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE OPIOID -- CURES ACT GRANT
FUNDS THIS IS THE DIVISION THAT
IS HANDLING THAT PARTICULAR AREA --
OF THE DEPARTMENTS EFFORT -- TO
ADMINISTER THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH
APPROXIMATELY -- THIRTY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROJECTS AND
THEN LASTLY -- WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE FACILITIES THAT COME IN --
SEEKING LICENSURE AS A
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY
AND SO SOME STAFFER NEEDED TO
HELP ON BOTH ADDRESS THAT
ONGOING WORKLOAD AS WELL AS I'M
TRY TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG AND
IN RESIDENTIAL APPLICATIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
JOHNSON DAILY -- WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ANON
CONTENT OF FINANCE NO COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WHAT'S UP UP UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
HI SIR IT IS THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS I GUESS I HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS THAN COMMONS --
THE ITEM IS KIND OF VAGUE AS TO
WHERE THE MONEY'S BEING APPLIED --
TO INCLUDES COUNSELORS -- BIZ
BROADLY AND THEN ANTI P.
REGULATION AND THEN SOME
EMERGENCY DISASTER AND WE'RE NOT
SURE WHAT ALLOCATION IS GOING TO
WHICH DIRECTION WE'D LIKE TO
KNOW MORE DETAIL ON THAT.
AS FAR AS THE EMERGENCY AND
DISASTER RESPONSE WE FEEL LIKE --
THE AMOUNT IS OVER INFLATED
BECAUSE AS MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND HE PIECE ALREADY
HAVE DISASTER RESPONSE.
REQUIREMENTS ANY HOME A
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY THAT'S
UNDER SIX BEDS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT EVACUATING AND FINDING A
PLACEMENT FOR SIX PEOPLE IN AND
MOVING STAFF AROUND.
MANY OF THE SMALLER PROGRAMS OWN
MORE THAN ONE FACILITY.
OUR BOARD MEMBER WHO OWNS THE
PROGRAM UP AND SHE GO HAD THIS
EXACT THING HAPPENED TO HER.
PROGRAM THIS PAST FALL AND SHE
WAS EASILY ABLE TO RELOCATE THE
PEOPLE IN HER SIX BEDS THE ONES
THAT ARE OVER SIXPENCE THE
LARGER FACILITIES ARE REQUIRED
BY THEIR LOCAL.
THERE ARE LOCAL AS ZONING CODES
TO HAVE EVACUATION PLANS --
WE'RE NOT SURE HOW THE NTP PART
OF IT IS.
IS ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED THERE
ARE LICENSING FUNDS THAT ARE
COLLECTED FOR THAT PURPOSE --
THE NEXT I DIDN'T START WITH I'M
ASSUMING THAT THE MONEY'S BEING
ALLOCATED ALREADY IN THE FUND.
AS OPPOSED TO AN INCREASE IN
LICENSING FEES AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S A CORRECT ASSUMPTION
OR NOT BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
HAS -- INFORMATION INFORMATION
NOTICE A THIRTY TO INCREASE FEES
IF THEY NEED TO SHOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
MONEY THIS ALREADY BEEN
COLLECTED AS OPPOSED TO RAISING
FEES.
AND I IT JUST ONE POINT OUT THAT
IN -- TWENTY FOURTEEN WE HAD AN
INCREASE IN FEES OF ONE HUNDRED
AND 10%.
ON RESIDENTIAL.
FOR A A DEFICIT OF EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
ROTH FUND.
AND THE ASK WAS FOR TWO POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
AT THE TIME WE COMPLAINED
VOCIFEROUSLY THAT.
THAT WAS TOO HIGH OF A RECENT
FEES GIVEN THE DEFICIT.
AND IF WE'RE NOT WORKING OUT.
OVER A MILLION DOLLARS NOT FUND
THAT'S NEEDING A HOME.
PERHAPS WE WERE RIGHT ABOUT THE
FEES BEING TOO HIGH.
WE ARE ONE OF THE ONLY STATES
THAT HAS A PER BED LICENSING FEE.
THIS CONSTRUCT ACCESS TO CARE
BECAUSE EVEN IN YOUR SMALLER
NONPROFIT SOCIAL MODELS THEY'RE
MAKING DETERMINATIONS ON HOW
MANY BEDS TO LICENSE.
BASED ON A THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLAR FEE PER BED.
SO IF THIS IS A TRULY.
TRYING TO FIND A HOME WE WOULD
PREFER THAT SOME ANALYSIS BE
DONE OF THE LICENSING.
OF FUN AND IF IT TRULY IS
RUNNING AND NOT HIGH OF IN THE
BLACK.
WE WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO SEE
AT LEAST FOR THE NON PROFITS THE
SMALLER WORLD PROGRAMS TO HAVE A
REDUCTION IN THEIR BED FEE.
OTHER STATES ARE ONLY FIVE THAT
CHARGE BED FEES AND THEY RANGE
FROM FIVE TO FIFTY DOLLARS OUR
SYSTEM HUNDRED AND FIFTY SO I
THINK SOME ANALYSIS.
OF THAT FUND NEEDS TO BE DONE WE
WERE PROMISED THAT WHEN THE FEE
INCREASE WENT THROUGH AND WE'D
LIKE TO SEE IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE I PROTESTED MINISTRATION TO
RESPOND. TO THE COMMENTS TO THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SURE SO I WILL HAVE TO GO --
BACK FROM A STANDPOINT OF
UNDERSTANDING THE FUNDS -- STEP --
THE LEVEL OF THE FUND AMOUNTS --
AND HOW THAT PERTAINS -- TO THAT
THE RELATIONSHIP FOR THE ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS AN APPROPRIATION
A SORTIE I DO KNOW THAT WITH
SPECIAL FUNDS AND WITH LICENSE
SCENE YOU KNOW WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THAT -- WE DON'T -- EXPEND
FUNDS ARE NOT AVAILABLE IN THE
ACCOUNT ITSELF I KNOW THAT -- WE
SAW LICENSURE -- INCREASES TO
RIGHT SIZE THE LICENSING FUND --
AS REFERENCE BEFORE IN THAT WE
HAD EXTRAORDINARY -- AN UP
SURGEON APPLICATIONS AFTER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WAS ENACTED
IN THAT OUT BECAUSE THERE'S NOW
A BENEFIT FOR SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT A LOT OF FACILITIES
WERE LOOKING TO COME INTO --
INTO BOTH THE STATE AS WELL AS
INTO HEALTH PLAN NETWORKS TO
HELP PROVIDE THAT SERVICE AND SO
OUR APPLICATIONS AND THE AMOUNT
OF LICENSURE ACTIVITY RELATED TO
THAT.
CERTAINLY NEEDED A RIGHT SIZING
IN THE FUN BUT I CAN GET YOU --
I FUND STATUS -- AND TALK TO MY
STAFF ABOUT -- SOME OF THE MORE.
CONCRETE DETAILS THAT WERE JUST
WHAT WERE JUST MENTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SPRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
EARLIER TODAY OUR FIRST -- THE
FIRST ITEM HAS TO DO WITH
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICES BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS. EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT CONCERNED THAT HAS
BEEN VOICED.
OVER AND OVER IS HOW WE WORK IN
SILOS -- WE GO BACK TO THE
HOMELESS ISSUE.
THAT THERE'S MONEY GOING TO SO
MANY DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
SOMEONE SOMEBODY NEEDS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT.
THEY DON'T REALLY KNOW WHICH
DEPARTMENT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
GO -- TO BUT DIFFERENT
APARTMENTS HAVE SOME DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS MONEY -- THAT THEY
HAVE TRAINING FOR OR THAT THEY
HAVE MONEY FOR SERVICES FOR A
MEDICAL SERVICES FOR MENTAL
SERVICES.
AND YET THEY'RE SILO ROAD IN SO
MANY WAYS THAT IN THE END YOU
DON'T KNOW WHERE THE PROPER.
ENTRY POINT IS -- THAT IS A
CONCERN AND I I KNOW FROM THE LA
OWES -- CONCERNS THAT WERE NOTED
IN IN.
THE DOCUMENT -- THERE WAS THAT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST
BREAKDOWN.
OF WHAT THE NEW STATE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
ARE -- IF THE IF YOU'VE TALKED
TO GENERALLY ABOUT THE NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES IS THERE
ANYTHING MORE SPECIFIC.
YOU CAN PROVIDE TO US ABOUT.
THE NEW RESPONSIBILITIES.
YOU'VE GIVEN THE FOR AREAS BUT
SURE SO -- WITHIN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY EACH OF US --
SO DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AM SO AWESOME HEAD WHEN
THERE IS A NATURAL DISASTER
DEPENDING ON WHAT THAT IS BE IT.
FIRE FLOOD -- EARTHQUAKE --
THERE IS A COORDINATED EFFORT AT
THE AGENCY LEVEL USUALLY IN
CONCERT WITH -- HELLO YES IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW ACTIVATION OF
THE STATE EMERGENCY COMMAND
CENTER AND SO -- HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY HAS FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS BEEN FAR
MORE AND AGGRESSIVE ABOUT HAVING
THE DEPARTMENTS A LEAN I GUESS
LEAN INTO THEIR LICENSED --
FACILITIES AND PROVIDER TYPES
WHEN A DISASTER OCCURS IN A
GIVEN SERVICE AREA SUCH THAT WE
ARE DOING.
CALLS TO FACILITIES WERE DOING
HEAT MAPPING -- SO THAT WITHIN
THE AGENCY AS WELL AS A COW --
YES THEY HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF
THE IMPACT OF THAT DISASTER IN
THOSE SERVICE AREAS SO THAT HAS
TURNED OUT TO BE A SIGNIFICANT --
STAFF INTENSIVE EXERCISE WE WILL
HAVE STAFF ON THE PHONE IN IN IN
LIKE IN THE IN THE WOLSELEY FIRE
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S AN EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER.
OF RESIDENTIAL AND OUTPATIENT
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
FACILITIES SO THAT WAS A
PARTICULARLY HIGH WORKLOAD IN
THAT PARTICULAR AREA.
BUT OBVIOUSLY -- THERE HAS BEEN
A LOT MORE -- INTEREST AT BOTH
KALLIO CAL -- YES AS WELL AS
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND.
HOW WE ARE COMMUNICATING WITH
THE LOCALS AS WELL AS
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENT
PROVIDER TYPES -- WHEN IT COMES
TO THE FEDERAL CURES ACT FUNDING --
THIS PARTICULAR DIVISION HAS
ESSENTIALLY -- ABSORBED THE THE
SIGNIFICANT INFLUX OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS WE HAVE I THINK
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY DIFFERENT
PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDER WAY AND
SO.
THESE INDIVIDUALS THROUGH THIS --
B. C. P. WOULD JUST BE HELPING
TO KIND OF SUPPORT THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN DOING THAT --
THERE'S A LOT OF GRANT DOLLARS
AN OVERSIGHT AND CONTRACT
MANAGEMENT THAT HAS BEEN DONE AS
A PART OF THAT SO.
THIS -- THE SEVEN POSITIONS WERE
REALLY MEANT.
TO YOU KNOW HANDLE THE KIND OF
TEMPORARY NATURE OF DISASTER
MANAGEMENT WORK ON THE FEDERAL
CURES ACT AS WELL AS JUST --
DEAL WITH THE CONSTANT -- INFLOW
OF APPLICATIONS FROM NEW
PROVIDERS OR THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH -- CONTINUAL WE
HAVE TO RECERTIFY THOSE --
FACILITIES ON A I THINK A THREE
YEAR BASIS SO IF YOU'VE BEEN
LICENSE AS A RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY WE GO BACK OUT WE
INSPECT YOU WE MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY THING IS STILL -- UP TO
DATE ON YOUR LICENSE AND OR IF
THERE'S A COMPLAINT SO THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF WORKLOAD THAT THIS
PARTICULAR DIVISION HAS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER.
TEN I'M SORRY ISSUE [inaudible]
ELEVEN AND ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE YES THANK YOU SO -- WE'RE
REQUESTING THE CONVERSION OF
THIRTEEN LIMITED TERM --
POSITIONS AS WELL AS A TWO YEAR
EXTENSION OF SEVEN POSITIONS --
THESE ARE POSITIONS -- SPLIT
BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT DIVISIONS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT -- OUR
ENTERPRISE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DIVISION AS
WELL AS IN OUR ELIGIBILITY
DIVISION.
WHEN -- THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
WAS PASSED WE CREATED -- A
SHARED IT SYSTEM BETWEEN US AND
COVER CALIFORNIA KNOWN AS CAL
HERE'S THAT SYSTEM -- CONNECTS
THROUGH A WE CALL IT THE HIT ME
AND I COULDN'T TELL YOU WHAT
THAT ACTUALLY STANDS FOR BUT IT
TALKS ESSENTIALLY TO THE THREE
COUNTY CONSORTIUM SYSTEMS.
THE STAFF THAT BOTH MAINTAIN OUR
EXISTING SYSTEMS WITHIN OUR OWN
DEPARTMENTS ENTERPRISE AS WELL
AS WORKING WITH THE CAL HERE'S
PROJECT AND AS WELL AS WORKING
WITH THE COUNTY SAUCE CONSORTIUM.
WE'RE SO WE KNOW THAT THAT
WORKLOAD -- IS CONTINUING --
FROM THE STANDPOINT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO BOTH MAINTAIN AND
MODIFY AND UPDATE THE SYSTEM AS
CHANGES ARISE YOU KNOW.
WITH RECENT EXAMPLE ABOUT THE
EXPANSION OF COVERAGE TO
INDIVIDUALS UP TO AGE TWENTY SIX
IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE WHERE WE
WOULD BE MAKING CHANGES TO CAL
HERE'S AND TESTING.
WITH THE SAUCE SYSTEM AND SO --
THESE ARE REALLY KIND OF KEEPING
THOSE CRITICAL RESOURCES IN
PLACE FROM OUR DEPARTMENT
STANDPOINT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
LAURIE I'VE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
WILL THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WERE STILL REVIEWING THIS
BUT DON'T HAVE ANY MAJOR
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
WEDDING QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWELVE ISSUE.
THIRTEEN SO THIS IS THE LAST
ITEM FOR OUR DEPARTMENT AND AS
YOU HEARD IN -- PREVIOUS --
COMMITTEE WE ARE SEEKING BOTH
RESOURCES AS WELL AS TRAILER
BILL AUTHORITY TO AFFECTION WAIT.
SOME OF OUR RECENT DEPARTMENT
CHANGES AROUND OVERSIGHT OF THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AS IT
ADULT.
COURSE THAT MEASURES -- WE HAVE
ANNOUNCED THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT PLANS ARE NOT MEETING THEIR
MINIMUM PERFORMANCE LEVEL THAT
WE WOULD BE PUTTING THEM UNDER
IMMEDIATE CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN.
PLACING THEM UNDER SANCTION WE
HAD A COUPLE OF OTHER INSTANCES
IN WHICH WE FEEL THAT WE NEED
MORE AND CONSISTENT SANCTION
AUTHORITY ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DIFFERENT -- DELIVERY SYSTEMS AS
WELL AS OUR DIFFERENT PROVIDER
TYPES AND SO WE'RE SEEKING
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO UPDATE
THAT AS WELL AS TO UPDATE THE
SANCTION AMOUNTS CONSISTENT WITH
THE FEDERAL ALLOWABLE AMOUNTS --
AND THEN LASTLY TO ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT WITH OUR EXISTING AND
EXTERNAL QUALITY REVIEW
ORGANIZATION AND HAVE THAT --
PROCESS BE EXEMPT FROM
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
REVIEW WHICH IS -- CONSISTENT
WITH HOW WE HAVE MOST OF OUR
CONTRACT APPROVALS AND IT'S
REALLY JUST A CONTRACT EXTENSION
FOR WORK THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING BUT WE ARE.
CHANGING AND MODIFYING THE
CONTRACT TO DO ADDITIONAL WORK
ON OUR BEHALF TO EFFECTUATE THE
CHANGES THAT WERE ANNOUNCED --
WITH THE WITH THE RECENT AUDIT
AS IT PERTAINED TO CHILDREN'S
PREVENTIVE MEASURES.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE --
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA -- BUT
WE DO THINK INCREASED OVERSIGHT
OF MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS
IS BOTH A PROMISING IN PRUDENT
APPROACH TO INCREASING QUALITY
IN THE PROGRAM -- WE HAVE NOT
SEEN THE TRAILER BILL YET BUT
WILL REVIEW IT IN THE COMING
DAYS AND WILL PROVIDE ANY
ASSESSMENTS ESPECIALLY IF WE
HAVE ANY CONCERNS BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO IT IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS.
THANK YOU.
I'M THE FINANCE JUST BECAUSE I
GUESS DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE AND NOTING THAT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WILL BE POSTED TO
OUR WEBSITE SOON.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU -- LET'S
OPEN IT UP TO THE PUBLIC.
BETH CAPELL HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE VERY LOOKING
FORWARD VERY MUCH TO SING THE
TRAILER BILL ON THIS WE WANT THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE AMPLE AUTHORITY
TO OVERSEE NOT ONLY THE MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS.
BUT THEIR SUBCONTRACTORS AND NOT
ONLY WITH RESPECT TO CHILD
PREVENTIVE SERVICES TO BUT TO
THE BROAD RANGE OF SERVICES
WHICH MEDI CAL COVERS WE WERE
VERY TROUBLED RECENTLY TO SEE
THE FAILURE OF A US
SUBCONTRACTORS CENTER BAD --
WHICH WAS A SUBCONTRACTOR WITH
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS THAT
WAS DENYING ACCESS TO
SPECIALISTS SUCH AS
CARDIOLOGISTS POLL MONOLOGIST
RADIOLOGIST OPHTHALMOLOGIST IN A
LONG LIST OF OTHER SPECIALS THAT
ARE BASIC. TO PEOPLE'S NEEDED
CARE AND SO WE WANT THE
DEPARTMENT TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE GET THE
CARE THEY NEED WHETHER CHILDREN
GETTING PREVENTIVE SERVICES. FOR
THE REST OF US GETTING THE CARE
THEY NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY -- ALIGNER
COMMENTS WITH HEALTH ACCESS WE
TO OF LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE -- GREATER
CONSIDERING OVER 80% OF MEDI CAL
AND RALLIES ARE IN MANAGED CARE
PLAN GREATER OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY OF THE PLANS AS
WELL AS THEIR DELEGATED ENTITIES
IS NEEDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER.
THIRTEEN ISSUE NUMBER
.
FOURTEEN PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SUBJECT LAB IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M HERE TO BRIEF THE
PROPOSED THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
UP PRESENT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE AND STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSES TO OFFER STATE
SUBSIDIES TO INDIVIDUALS.
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND 6100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
IT CONTINUES THE INTENT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO MAINTAIN A
BUDGET NEUTRAL POT PROGRAM OVER
THE FORECAST PERIOD SO IS
PROPOSING.
TO FUNDED THE INCREASE OF THE
PROGRAM WITH THE PENALTY REVENUE
GENERATED BY THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE -- COMPARED TO INITIAL
ESTIMATE SURE AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PENALTY REVENUE
PROJECTIONS ARE DOWN BY
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD.
SO I GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
ROUGHLY ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
SB REVISION WE BELIEVE IT'S A
ROUGHLY.
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS AS NO
BEEN FOR THIS ESTIMATE TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
FILING TAX THRESHOLD WHICH MEANS
FEWER INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE PENALTY.
UP BEYOND THAT WE TOOK THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN FEDERAL DATA GREW
IT BY PROJECTION ASSUMING THAT
MORE INDIVIDUALS WOULD.
NO LONGER BE COVERED BY
INSURANCE BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
THE FEDERAL PENALTY.
FOR THIS TAX YEAR AND FROM THERE
WE DISCOUNTED BY THE INCREASE
CALIFORNIA FILING THRESHOLD --
SO AS A RESULT OF THE CHANGE IN
THE PENALTY REVENUE WE'RE
PROPOSING PROGRAM EXPENSES OF
TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION IN. NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
POINT FOUR MILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE POINT NINE
MILLION IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO UP FOR
COVERAGE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
BASED ON ESTIMATES PROVIDED BY
COVER CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE THE
PROGRAM WILL RESULT IN
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING STATE SUBSIDIES.
THROUGH THE EXCHANGE RESULTING
AND A HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND NEWLY INSURED.
INDIVIDUALS.
SO ON TO YOUR QUESTIONS WHY ARE
WE PROPOSING THE SONS TO SUNSET
THE SUBSIDIES BUT NOT THE
MANDATE.
AS PREVIOUSLY REFERENCED IN OUR
TESTIMONY ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS SUNSET WILL GIVE US TIME TO
RE EVALUATE THE MERITS OF THE
PROPOSAL THE PROGRAM.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT.
ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABILITY.
OF COMPONENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL
WILL REQUIRES STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERSHIP.
AND BUILDING IN THE SUNSET TIME
WILL ALLOW US TO REASSESS.
AT THAT TIME ADDITIONALLY WE
HAVE ANOTHER PROPOSAL.
TO CREATE THE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL COMMISSION WHICH WILL BE
ANALYZING DIFFERENT SINGLE PAYER
PROPOSALS.
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY RELEASED THE
REPORT IN THE NEXT YEAR AND A
HALF.
AT WHICH TIME WE WILL BE ABLE TO
USE THAT DATA TO REASSESS THIS
PROGRAM.
OF ON YOUR SECOND OR THIRD
QUESTION COULD HOUSEHOLDS CLOSE
24100% OF THE FPL BE SUBJECT TO
A LARGE RECONCILIATION -- YES OR
PROPOSAL INCLUDES RECONCILIATION --
OF THE INDIVIDUAL STEPS IN
BOUNCE AND INDIVIDUAL PENALTY
PAYMENTS -- WE THINK THAT
RECONCILIATION IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE WE HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
EXCEEDS THE FEDERAL.
OF PROGRAM THAT'S CURRENTLY IN
PLACE THAT IT STOPS OFFERING
FIDDLES IS ASSISTANCE AT FOUR
HUDRED F. P. L..
IF WE DON'T MAINTAIN THE
RECONCILIATION COMPONENT OF OUR
PROPOSAL THERE COULD BE
INSTANCES WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE
JUST ABOVE OR JUST BELOW THAT.
THRESHOLD AND RECEIVING BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE ASSISTANCE
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
PREFER TO AVOID.
AND THEN DOES THIS PROPOSAL MAKE
A MEANINGFUL FED FOR INDIVIDUALS
BELOW FOR HER PERCENT F. PEEL
BASED OFF THE MODELING THAT
COVER CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD RESULT AND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND APPROXIMATELY NEW
INDIVIDUALS AND ROLLED.
IN INSURANCE BELOW THE HOLE
4100% FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
OF FURTHER COVER CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD REDUCE PREMIUM GROWTH BY.
UP 28% -- IN COVER YOUR TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN FINALLY HOW
RAPIDLY DUE OUT YOUR COSTS GROW.
IF WE DO NOT MODIFY THE PROGRAM
DESIGNED IN THE OUT YEARS.
SO WORKING WITH COVER CALIFORNIA
WE IDENTIFIED TWO PRIMARY
FACTORS THAT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT OUT YOUR COST GROWTH
IS YOUR PREMIUM GROWTH AND THEN
THE GROWTH OF PERSONAL INCOME IF
THE GROWTH OF PERSONAL INCOME
DOES NOT KEEP.
PACE WITH THE COST OF PREMIUMS.
THE STATE SHARE OF COST FOR
INDIVIDUALS PREMIUM INCREASES
RAPIDLY.
SO BASED OFF THE MALL THAT WE
HAVE PROPOSED TODAY ROUGHLY IF
WE MAINTAIN THIS MODEL IN YOUR
ONE YEAR TWO AND YEAR -- THREE
WE BELIEVE THAT THE COST FOR
INDIVIDUALS ABOVE FOUR HUNDRED
F. P. L. COULD GROW BY UP 230%
IN YOUR ONE AND THEN ANOTHER 30%
IN YOUR TWO RESULTING IN
ADDITIONAL COSTS OF RANGING
BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION -- FOR THOSE TWO
ADDITIONAL YEARS -- WE LIKE TO
NOTE THAT OUR INTENT IN
DESIGNING THIS PROGRAM IS TO
MAINTAIN AN AVERAGE SUBSIDY
AMOUNT ABOVE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
ABOVE FOUR HUNDRED F. P. L. OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
MONTH.
AND MAINTAIN THAT AVERAGE
MONTHLY SUBSIDY FOR INDIVIDUALS
BELOW FOUR HUNDRED A MONTH AT
ABOUT TEN DOLLARS.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
GOING STRAIGHT TO THE QUESTIONS
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE TO ASK.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
BROWN WAS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- LIKE ALL OF
THE OTHER PROPOSALS IN THE MAYOR
VISION OUR OFFICE CONTINUES TO
EVALUATE THESE AS AS ADDITIONAL
DETAIL IS IS COMING OUT WERE
REVIEWING THIS SPECIFIC BENEFIT
PARAMETERS THAT WERE JUST.
DESCRIBED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- IN TERMS OF SPECIFIC
COMMENTS THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
THEM AT THIS POINT I'M JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THAT -- AS WITH --
OTHER.
AT PROPOSES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THIS INVOLVES A SUNSET.
AND IT HAS SOME OF THE SAME
ISSUES THAT WE'VE DESCRIBED
RIVAS LEE ABOUT -- POTENTIAL
COST PRESSURES IN THE OUT YEARS
IN THE BUDGET -- WHERE IT T MAY
BE DIFFICULT TO TO END THIS
BENEFIT -- EVEN THOUGH THE THE
THE MULTI YEAR AND HIS BALANCED
ON THE PREMISE THAT.
THIS BENEFIT WOULD BE SUNSET --
SO THAT'S SOMETHING FOR IT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER --
BEYOND THAT AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS --
WHETHER THE ALLOCATION OF THE
PENALTY REVENUES TO INDIVIDUALS
ABOVE 4100% OF F. P. L. WHO
CURRENTLY RECEIVE NO ASSISTANCE.
VERSES INDIVIDUALS BELOW 4100%
OF F. P. L. WHO DO RECEIVE
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE IS CONSISTENT
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
THE GOVERNOR HAS.
PROPOSED TO SPEND THE MAJORITY
THE REVENUES FOR THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON SUBSIDIZED.
AND THAT HAS POLICY MERITS IN
THAT DOWN THOSE INDIVIDUALS --
CURRENTLY HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST COSTS.
BUT AS A SIDE RESULT AM VERY
LITTLE IS IS LEFT FOR THE THE
GROUP THAT'S BELOW SO THAT'S
SOMETHING FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER AS WELL -- BEYOND THAT
WILL ADD UP.
UPDATE THE LEGISLATURE WITH ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THAT WE HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN CHAIR KATIE RAVEL DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND RESEARCH IT COVER
CALIFORNIA DON'T HAVE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU.
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
BEST PAL IN BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA.
LIKE TO START OFF BY SAYING THAT
WE APPRECIATED THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS APPROACH
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABILITY HELP.
BUT WE ARE UNHAPPY THAT IT IS
LIMITED TO THE REVENUE RAISED BY
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
WE DO THINGS OF THE HELP IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE PEOPLE
410026100% OF POVERTY WHO
THE FEDERAL SUBSIDY.
A MARRIED COUPLE IN THEIR LATE
FIFTIES OR EARLY SIXTIES WHO
WANTED TO BUY THE STANDARD
SILVER PLAN COULD SPEND AS MUCH
AS 40% OF THEIR INCOME.
ON THE PREMIUM ALONE AND
OBVIOUSLY FAMILIES IN THAT
SITUATION MAKE DIFFICULT CHOICES
AND SOMETIMES BY THE SKINNIER
PLAN WITH THE SIX THOUSAND
DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE FOR EACH OF
THEM OR ONE OF THEM THE ONE THEY
HOPE IS HEALTHY GOES WITHOUT
COVERAGE IN HOPES THEY CAN MAKE
IT TO MEDICARE.
SO WE DO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S HELP FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE 410026100% OF POVERTY.
BUT WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
GOVERNOR IS NOT WILLING TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO MAKE LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE AND
I'M SORRY I CAN'T HAVE A CHOICE
BETWEEN SEEING MY PAPER AND
SEEING YOU MISTER MATHESON IT'S
JUST -- SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOMEBODY UNDER THE CURRENT
FEDERAL LAW.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
COVERED CALIFORNIA WHO ARE ON
THE SAME INCOME RANGE IS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON MEDICARE ALL.
THEY'RE PAYING TWENTY FIVE OR
THIRTY DOLLARS A MONTH FOR THEIR
PREMIUM IF THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL TWENTY FIVE OR THIRTY
DOLLARS A MONTH DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE A LOT OF MONEY UNTIL YOU
REALIZE FOR TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
LIVING ON TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH.
THEN IT'S REAL MONEY WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE OUR ESTIMATE IS THAT COST
TEN OR FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE.
WE ALSO HAVE PEOPLE MAKING.
BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND 38% OF
POVERTY IN 2100% OF POVERTY
THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND TO
TWENTY FOUR OR THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AGAIN THAT WE'RE ASKING THEM TO
SPEND FIFTY A HUNDRED A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY DOLLARS A MONTH ON
THEIR PREMIUM SUCH A LOT OF
MONEY WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO LIVE
ON THAT KIND OF INCOME.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
PROPOSAL CUTS OFF HELP AT 2100%
OF POVERTY WE UNDERSTOOD IT WHEN
IT HAD TO DO WITH COPAYS AND
DEDUCTIBLES BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PREMIUMS NOW.
SO WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE CUT
OFF A 2100% WE ALSO DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE ISN'T MORE
GENERAL FUND HELP.
THAT GOES BEYOND WHAT THE
MANDATE PENALTY RAISES FOR A
COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION MORE ON
GOING WE COULD PROVIDE REAL HELP
FOR ALL THE PEOPLE I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
WE'RE ALSO PERPLEXED WHY WE HAVE
A SUNSET ON THE AFFORDABILITY
AND NOT ON THE MANDATE THE
MANDATE IS AN EQUALLY
COMPLICATED IN NEW THING TO DO
AT THE STATE LEVEL WE SUPPORT
THE MANDATE.
BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO SUNSET ONE
WE SHOULD PROBABLY SUNSET THE
OTHER OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO
PENALIZE PEOPLE WHEN MOST OF YOU
KNOW IS CERTAINLY EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL I'VE DEALT WITH KNOWS.
THAT THE REASON PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE COVERAGE AS THEY CAN'T
AFFORD IT AND SO THE
AFFORDABILITY HELP GOES HAND IN
HAND WITH THE MANDATE.
THIRD WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WE
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE DOING TAX
RECONCILIATION OF WERE PROVIDING
PEOPLE HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS OF
HELP OR SOMEONE.
IS BELOW THE 4100% THRESHOLD
THEY GO OVER AND THEN THE GOD IF
YOU PAY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BACK ALL THE HELP THEY GOT WE
WANT TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY A FOR A
MEASLY TEN BUCKS A MONTH WERE
TAKING PEOPLE THROUGH TAX
RECONCILIATION WE JUST.
THAT IS INCOMPREHENSIBLE TO US.
WE ALSO DON'T OF YOU'RE WELCOME
SIR WE ALSO DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THIS PROPOSAL STILL INCLUDES
HEALTH CARE SHARING MINISTRY IS
WHICH DESTABILIZE THE INDIVIDUAL
INSURANCE MARKET.
AND WHICH ALLOW INTO WHICH ALLOW
ARE ALLOWED TO DISCRIMINATE ON
HEALTH CONDITIONS AND OTHER
FACTORS.
SO WE'RE YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF GOOD STUFF IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I'M JUST GIVING YOU A
LONG LIST OF PROBLEMS WITH THAT
SO WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE TO BE
HERE AND HAVING THE CONVERSATION.
BUT THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
THAT WE HOPE GET RESOLVED OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS AS YOU CLOSE
DOWN THIS BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE DO APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
AFFORDABILITY BUT BELIEVE IT'S
INSUFFICIENT -- PARTICULARLY AS
IT EXCLUDES INDIVIDUALS BELOW
2100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL -- AND SO -- WE BELIEVE
THAT ANY REINSTATEMENT OF THE
PENALTY SHALL I SHOULD INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE FOR INDIVIDUALS BELOW
2100% OF THE FPL AS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE MORE PRICE
SENSITIVE AND DATA HAS SHOWN.
THAT THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO
ENROLL IN COVERED CALIFORNIA
WITH ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE ARE
WE TOO ARE COMPLEX WITH THAT
SUCH AS THESE.
SUDDEN SETTING IN THREE YEARS --
DESPITE THE PENALTY CONTINUING
IN PERPETUITY -- AND SHARE THE
CONCERNS REGARDING -- HEALTH
CARE SHARING MINISTRY IS AS AS
THESE ARE UNREGULATED -- PLANS --
AND IF OF FINALLY -- WE DO
BELIEVE INSURANCE AFFORDABILITY
PROGRAM SHOULD INCLUDE SUBSIDIES
AS PART OF THE DEFINITION TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO WRONG
DOOR THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER ALI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS AND WE DO SUPPORT --
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WE THINK
THAT'LL HELP STABILIZE THE
MARKET.
AND ACTUALLY HELP TO YOU KNOW
REDUCE MAKE WITH THE HEALTHCARE
INSURANCE POOL REDUCE THE ON
GOING COSTS.
AND SO ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
MR BUT I JUST WANT TO THANK OUR
OUR FIRST LADY FROM THE PUBLIC
MA'AM YOU STILL ALL MY I I
SHOULD THEY WOULD GREAT MINDS
THINK ALIKE SO SO THANK YOU FOR
SAYING WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY AND
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
PRESENTATION.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER.
FIFTEEN SO ON ISSUE FIFTEEN
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IS NOT
AVAILABLE AT THIS MOMENT TO
ROUTE [inaudible]
SO.
BECAUSE THIS IS A ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT TWO OR THREE
MINUTES
.
THERE IS A VERY ACCURATE TO
COUNTING THAT IN. TWO TO THREE
MINUTES YOU WOULD BE HERE.
AND I THINK IT TOOK TWO TO THREE
SECONDS.
THAT'S WHAT HE MEANT TO SAY.
ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JEANNIE HERMAN WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER THERE --
THANKS FOR HEARING OR BUDGETARY
CHANGE PROPOSAL.
THE BET TO IMPLEMENT THE MANDATE
PENALTY.
ON SUBSIDY PROPOSALS UP TO BE IS
ASKING FOR VARIOUS RESOURCES
BEGINNING IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THROUGH THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
TAX YEAR OR FISCAL YEAR.
AS A PROGRAM IN AFTER THESE
COMPLAINTS EFFORTS MUST FULLY
MATURE.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY I TO BE IS
ASKING SOLELY FOR IT RESOURCES
SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING.
THE TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
AFTER THE REQUEST RESOURCES FOR
RETURN PROCESSING INVALIDATION.
CUSTOMER ASSISTANCE. FIVE
ENFORCEMENT COLLECTION ACTIVITY
AND TO GUARD AGAINST AN
APPROPRIATE PAYMENT OF BENEFITS.
FINALLY IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE OF TO BE WILL REDUCE
POSITION OF AUTHORITY FOR RECESS
ON RESOURCES FOR OUR TECHNOLOGY
STUFF THAT WERE NEEDED FOR A NE
TIME EFFORT TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS.
THESE RESOURCES ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURE A TO BECOME A MINISTER
THESE PROVISIONS AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
BRIAN WITH THE FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED APPROACH BY FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO PLUMBING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- WE'RE HERE FOR THE
ANSWER QUESTIONS WE HAVE ANY.
WONDERFUL LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
BETH BELFER HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA WE DO SUPPORT THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE WE ALSO AS
PART OF THE BALANCED PACKAGE OF
REFORMS THAT WAS THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT THAT WE'RE CONTINUING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE SUPPORT HAVE TO BE HAVING THE
RESOURCES THAT IT NEEDS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE TRAILER BILL
HAS.
ANY NUMBER OF PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THE FTV CAN COLLECT
MONEY FROM TAXPAYERS.
WE WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD ALSO
SEE PROVISIONS THAT IF THE
TAXPAYER PAYS THE PENALTY IN
ERROR THAT THEY HAVE TO BE WILL
ASSIST THEM IN GETTING IT
REFUNDED.
MANY CONSUMERS PAY HAVE PAID THE
PENALTY AN ERROR AND DON'T
REALIZE THAT THEY'VE MADE THE
MISTAKE AND SHOULD APPLY FOR A
REFUND -- AND SO WE'RE NOT CLEAR
THAT THE LANGUAGE PROVIDES QUITE
THOSE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BUT
WE DO SUPPORT AFTER BE HAVING
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO
IMPLEMENT THIS ON SUCH A SHORT
TIME FRAMES.
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY JUST WOULD LIKE
TO REITERATE OUR COMMENT ANY
REINSTATEMENT OF THE MANDATE
PENALTY INCLUDE.
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE FOR
THOSE BELOW 2100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL I'M NOT REQUIRE
RECONCILIATION FOR THOSE -- I
GETTING LET A TEN DOLLARS A
MONTH AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO PAID THE PENALTY IN
ERROR ARE PROVIDED THE
APPROPRIATE REFINED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
GOOD I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON ISSUE.
FIFTEEN ISSUE SIXTEEN INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CONTROL PROPOSAL
.
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE
I'M TURN MEMBERS THE CLOSER FOR
CERTAIN THE MY CLOSER TO YOU.
HI SUSAN VALLEY CHIEF DEPUTY FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH I JUST WANT TO
START WITH A COUPLE COMMENTS AND
THEN JAMES WHAT DOCTOR WHAT WILL
GIVES -- MORE DETAIL.
BUT WE ARE COMMITTED TO YOU WITH
THE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS --
ACROSS THE STATE FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CONTROL -- WE ARE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING THAT
INFLEXIBLE FUNDING AND COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH SHE ACTS UCLA
JOE AND HOW ACT TO COME UP WITH
A PLAN HOW TO BEST SPAM THESE
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS --
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT -- WE'RE
ASKING FOR EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN STATE OPERATIONS THAT WILL
INCLUDE NOT ONLY THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THESE FUNDS
BUT ALSO.
BE LOOKING AT PROVIDING SOME
TECHNICAL EXPERTS OUT WITH.
GIVE UTILIZING AID AN INTER
AGENCY AGREEMENT WITH THE UC
DAVIS OR ANOTHER ENTITY TO
PROVIDE THOSE TECHNICAL EXPERTS.
IN THE DEPARTMENT THAT CAN BE
BOTH I'M LOOKING AT A VALUATION
OF THE FUNDS LOOKING AT SOME
STATEWIDE -- SURVEILLANCE APPY
BUT ALSO THEN PROVIDING BOOTS ON
THE GROUND WHEN THERE IS AN
OUTBREAK THAT WE CAN -- PUT
THOSE PEOPLE OUT IN THE FIELD TO
ASSIST THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
SO WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT EIGHT
MILLION AS OF A LARGER
PERCENTAGE THAN WE WOULD
NORMALLY -- TAKEN STATE
OPERATIONS BUT IT'S NOT JUST FOR
ADMINISTRATION IT'S BOTH
ADMINISTRATION AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE -- AND SO WE ARE
COMMITTED TO LOOKING AT THAT --
RATIO AND THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
REALLY DO FUND OUR TRIBES AND
WHETHER THAT IS SOMETHING WE
CARVE OUT OF THE STATE
OPERATIONS PEACE AND DO --
SOMETHING WITH CRIB OR WITH SOME
OTHER TRIBAL ENTITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE USING THE FUNDS AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
SOME HAD TURNED IT OVER TO JAMES
WATT.
THANK YOU I JAMES WHAT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
I JUST TO ADD BRIEFLY TO THAT --
THE WORK I HAVE INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CONTROL IS REALLY -- FOR
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- MOST OF THE
FUNDS WILL SUPPORT LOCAL EFFORTS
AND THEN WE WOULD INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE EXPERTISE
AND A SPECIALIZED RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THEM AS THEY NEED --
GOING FORWARD AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY APOLOGIES SO NEW PADDICK
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
MS FINALE ACTUALLY JUST
ADDRESSED LARGELY ADDRESSED THE
CONCERNS WE'VE HAD ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL ONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ENOUGH OF THE FUNDING
GOING TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS RATHER THAN
STAYING WITH STATE OPERATIONS --
THE TWO THAT THE MONEY REMAIN
FLEXIBLE BOTH IN A AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BOTH IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
SPEND IT BUT ALSO AND IN TERMS
OF GIVING THE THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS.
THE MONEY UP FRONT SO THEY CAN
USE IT IN A FLEXIBLE WAY OVER
THE FOUR YEAR PERIOD AND THEN
THIRD -- JUST.
FINDING OUT WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S PLAN WAS FOR
WORKING WITH A TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS -- SO.
THANK YOU FOR ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS ALREADY AND THAT'S ALL
WE HAD.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
YOU ENTER ALMOST DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS SHOWS OF WHEN I
REITERATE THAT.
THE FUNDING WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO LOCAL HEALTH RESTRICTIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE TRAVEL COMMUNITY.
I'M SORRY YOU SAID TO LOCAL.
PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND TRIBAL.
AND TRAVEL COMMUNITIES A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WILL ALSO BE HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
MONEY.
THE INTENT OF THE FUNDING WOULD
BE DIRECTLY GOING TO LOCAL
HOSTERS SECTIONS A LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS CONDENSE A
CONTRACT WITH A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
AS LINE WHICH IS CURRENTLY READ.
THEIR GOOD THAT WAS GOING TO BE
A SPECIFIC QUESTION OF MINE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN THIS UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'M SURE MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AS A STANDALONE MAY
WRITE ME REVISED PROPOSAL.
HOWEVER IF THIS IS THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THE ADMINISTRATION INTENDS
TO RESPOND TO THE STD --
EPIDEMIC THEN IT'S A
UNFORTUNATELY HOLY AN ADEQUATE --
THERE IS A PROPOSAL FOR FOUR
YEARS OF FUNDING WE'VE BEEN DOWN
THIS ROAD BEFORE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN YOU ALL APPROPRIATED
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WAS CARRIED OVER FOR THREE
YEARS I COULD ONLY STILL BE USED
FOR PURCHASING -- ISSUE -- ITEMS
AND TEST KITS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BUT COULD NOT BE USED TO
PAY FOR ON THE GROUND BOOKS ON
THE GROUND PEOPLE ACTUALLY DO
THE WORK -- WHICH IS WHAT'S
REALLY DRIVING THE EPIDEMIC NOW.
IT'S ALSO TOO LITTLE AMOUNT OF
MONEY -- STDS HAVE BEEN HOLE ARE
SORELY FUNDED OVER THE LAST
DECADE OR MORE -- AND TO PUT
TWELVE FORTY MILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS TO COVER NOT ONLY STDS BUT
ALL OTHER INFECTIOUS DISEASES
MEANS THAT ONLY HAPPENS WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ANY OF THOSE
DISEASES LET ALONG.
THE ONE THAT IS ESCALATING MORE
RAPIDLY THAN THAN -- ANY OTHERS --
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER I
CONTINUE TO CONSIDER THE
PROPOSAL IS BEFORE YOU. ONE
OTHER POINT I WOULD MAKE AN THAT
IS RELATIVE TO THE DIRECTION TO
LOCAL -- FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE --
THERE IS NOTHING IN LAW NOW THAT
GIVES DPH ANYMORE ROBUST --
DIRECTION ABOUT HOW THEY SHOULD
BE DEALING WITH ASK YOU DO YOU
CRISIS ON THE GROUND I'M YOU ARE
LOOKING AT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WE HOPE WILL CONSIDER THAT
WILL ACTUALLY GIVE THEM SOME
GREATER DIRECTION.
ABOUT HOW THEY CAN USE THOSE
FUNDS MORE EFFECTIVELY WE THINK
THAT'S A MUCH MORE.
ROBUST PACKAGE FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER THEM THAN THIS ONE AS
FAR AS TNCS ARE CONCERNED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIVENS
OF THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST WHEN A COMMAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE PROPOSAL
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH FUNDING JUST
STATEWIDE GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING BUT
WE DEFINITELY VIEW THIS IS THAT
INVESTMENT AND AND AN UP FRONT
APPROACH -- AND SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DISCUSSES THE
YEARS TO COME A FEW THINGS THAT
I WOULD JUST NOTE ON IT IS AND
YOU KNOW WE DEFINITELY I THINK
IN TERMS OF HOW THE FUNDING IS
DISTRIBUTED.
IF YOU DO TEN MILLION A YEAR
OVER FOUR YEARS IT'S REALLY NOT
ENOUGH -- WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH TO FIX A FOR YOUR
WORTH OF DUTIES AND SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE CAN MAXIMIZE THE
FUNDING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IF
YOU PROVIDE THAT INVESTMENT UP
FRONT. FORTY MILLION DISTRIBUTED
AT AS A WITH A LUMP SUM GRANT
TELL TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS SO
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE A
CONSIDERATION OF THAT WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE ALLEGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAINTAIN THE FLEXIBILITY IN
THE FUNDING TO NOT GO BACK TO
BEING DISEASE SPECIFIC BUT TO
ALLOW IT TO CONTINUE TO BE.
FLEXIBLE AND FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AT SOME
JURISDICTIONS MAY PRIORITIZE THE
CD'S OTHERS MAY HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE A VALLEY FEVER AND IS
MY MEMBER CAME BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND
STATED.
I MEAN SHE HAS HAD A CASES AND
HAS TO PREVENT MEASLES OUTBREAK
AND STILL NEEDS TO GRAPPLE WITH
STDS -- THE CASES THAT ARE
INCREASING SO THAT FLEXIBILITY
IS IS REALLY NEEDED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND THE OTHER PIECE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT MISS FINALES
COMMENTS ABOUT INCLUDING TI
COLLECT AND SEE SEE LATE SHOW.
IN THE DISCUSSION AS THE
DISTRIBUTION IN THE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY IS CREATED WE THINK
THAT'S VITAL.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE UTILIZING THESE FUNDSAND
WE SHOULD HAVE THIS S. PLACE AT
THE TABLE INTO IN DETERMINING
HOW THAT ALLOCATION IS ADD.
DISTRIBUTED SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU KAT TO BURKE WITH THE
HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL AN ECHOING THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHI ACT
THAT WE SUPPORT THE THE NON SEE
SPECIFIC NATURE.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING UP
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF RIVERSIDE VENTURA
AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IS WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE RECOGNITION OF THE
INVESTMENT THAT IS.
CRITICALLY NEEDED AND PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
STATE -- AND I WOULD ALIGN
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY
CHECK AND HOW I CAN WE'D LIKE TO
SEE SOME FLEXIBILITY HERE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
COURTNEY MALL HER PEERS AND I'M
HERE FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION ALSO REPRESENTING
THAT CALIFORNIA TO THE ALLIANCE
AND THE CALIFORNIA HEPATITIS
ALLIANCE -- WANTED TO VOICE OUR
SUPPORT WE RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR I'M IN INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND ALSO WANTED TO BE CLEAR THAT
THAT -- ATV EIGHT CD AN STD
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO PUSH FOR
A SPECIFIC INVESTMENT IN HVAC
THE AN STD -- PREVENTION
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THANK
YOU AROUND THE ABILITY OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
APPLY FOR THAT FUNDING -- WE ARE
REQUESTING A SIXTY MILLION
DOLLAR REINVESTMENT IN
PREVENTION WE WOULD URGE THAT
COUNTIES BUT ALSO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS -- ARE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR THAT
FUNDING -- IN SOME CASES THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE THE GROUPS ON THE GROUND
MORE CLOSELY WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND AWARE OF THAT THE
NEEDS OF THOSE VARIOUS -- REALLY
AT RISK COMMUNITIES SO THE
FLEXIBILITY IS KEY FOR THAT --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON SO BECAUSE THE
A HERE REPRESENTING ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE AND THE EPIDEMICS
COALITION -- WERE ALSO AS WELL
GRATEFUL FOR THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS INVESTMENT IT'S A GREAT
START TO HEALTHY START TO START
REBUILDING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT AND OUR ABILITY TO RAPIDLY
RESPOND OUTBREAKS BUT THE S. T.
HIV AND HABSI EPIDEMICS HAVE
GONE ON FOR FAR TOO LONG. FOR
RAPID RESPONSE WHERE RAPID
RESPONSE IS NO LONGER SUFFICIENT
WE NEED A COORDINATED STATEWIDE
STRATEGIC PLAN AN INCREASE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
OF THAT'S WHY THE AND THE
EPIDEMICS UP COALITION IT'S
URGENT NEED TO INVEST AT LEAST
TWO OR OR INTENT BEST TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO CREATE A TASK
FORCE I CAN TAKE ON THE CREATION
OF SUCH A PLAN.
AT TO REALLY HELPED START
ADDRESSING THE END OF IT AT THE
TOPIC THAT MIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IS A MAN
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
FARMING DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL.
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
THE COUNTY FOLKS ABOUT
FLEXIBILITY AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF WORKING WITH THE AFFILIATES
IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO MAKE
SURE THIS FUNDING.
TRICKLES DOWN IN THE COMMUNITY
ROOM WHERE IT'S NEEDED MOST
THANK YOU.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO ONCE SUPPORT OF
AN APPRECIATIVE OF THE FUNDING
AND IN ALIGNMENT WITH CHIA CAN
SEE SACKING THEIR OTHER COMMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
REPRESENTING SAMPOERNA DINO.
IT'S A LITTLE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S.
BRING IT BACK TO THE TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I THINK IT WAS CLEAR FROM THE
FROM THE COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC IS THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AYE AYE --
AND I THINK EVERYBODY WAS VERY
KIND ABOUT IT THIS IS A GOOD
BEGINNING BECAUSE IT IS.
THERE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
WONDERFUL PROPOSALS -- REGARDING
SPECIFICALLY HIV SPECIFICALLY
STDS HAVE HEPATITIS AND SOME OF
THE OTHERS AND IN THE END IT WAS
ALL PUT INTO ONE FUND.
OVER A PERIOD OF FOUR YEARS.
IT IT I WHETHER IT'S GOING TO BE
ENOUGH FOR NOT I THINK THE
PUBLIC HAS SPOKEN AS TO THE FACT
THAT IT PROBABLY IS NOT.
I DO APPRECIATE THAT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT THROUGH THE
COUNTIES -- THAT.
THAT IS AN EXTRA IN IMPORTANT --
POINT I DO THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT.
ANYTHING ELSE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING NOTHING I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION [inaudible]
ISSUE.
SEVENTEEN MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DO
JOHNSON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WOULD YOU BRING IT CLOSER TO YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE STATUTORY CHANGE PROPOSAL
WOULD ALLOW THE OFFICE OF AIDS.
TO ESTABLISH A NEW FINANCIAL
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENT FOR ITS
HIV CARE PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE WITH HIV.
THAT WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH
THAT THE REQUIREMENTCURRENTLY
IN PLACE FOR THE EIGHT HOUR
PROGRAM AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM -- THE HIV CARE PROGRAM
SERVES ABOUT THIRTEEN THOUSAND
CLIENTS YEAR IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
IT HAS TWENTY ONE DIFFERENT
SERVICE CATEGORIES FOR
WRAPAROUND SERVICES INCLUDING
LIKE CASE MANAGEMENT ATTRITION
TRANSPORTATION FOOD DELIVERY
ETCETERA.
THERE WAS A HER SO -- AUDIT A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT IDENTIFIED
THAT WE NEED TO BECOME COMPLIANT
WITH A A FEDERAL REQUIREMENT.
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS IT'S
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING THAT TO THE
AID UP AND SO IT'S GONNA BE A
LARGELY A TECHNICAL CHANGE THAT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY IF APPROVED.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
S. SENATE PARTICULARLY -- WE
AGREE THIS IS LARGELY A
TECHNICAL CHANGE AND JUST
SUGGEST THE LEGISLATURE MAY MAY
WISH TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT --
HOW IT INTENDS TO HANDLE THE
POPULATION THAT WOULD NO LONGER
BE ELIGIBLE UNDER THESE NEW
INCOME RULES BECAUSE THEIR
INCOMES ARE TOO HIGH?
THANK YOU -- FROM FINANCE.
ALRIGHT THEN I WOULD ASK THE THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO TO RESPOND TO
THE LA OWES -- QUESTION.
YES.
SO IT'S A RELATIVELY SMALL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD
REQUIRE -- SOME ADDITIONAL
NAVIGATION THERE'S THIRTEEN
THOUSAND TOTALING WE'VE
IDENTIFIED NINETY ONE OF THOSE
FOLKS WHO WOULD NO LONGER BE
ELIGIBLE WITH THE 5100%.
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEIR ENROLLMENT
WORKERS TO ENSURE THAT THE GET
ENROLLED IN IT COVER CALIFORNIA --
OR OTHER INSURANCE -- SUBSIDY.
I WANT TO BE SURE THE THE ANSWER
SUFFICIENT BEFORE WE MOVE ON ALL
RIGHT TO OF PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE.
HI AGAIN CREDIT MOTOR PEARSON
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION THE CALIFORNIA ATV
ALLIANCE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BRING YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
ISSUE.
EIGHTEEN WELCOME BACK HELLO
AGAIN SUSANVILLE AYE CHIEF
DEPUTY FOR PUBLIC HEALTH -- THIS
PROPOSAL IS TWELVE FOR TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND FIFTEEN
POSITIONS FROM THE EDUCATION
PREVENTION AND USE FUND FOR
CANNABIS -- IT BUILDS ON WHAT
ARE ONE TIME FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVED FROM DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR A YOUTH --
CAMPAIGN ON THE RISKS OF
CANNABIS AND SO WHAT WE DID WAS
BUILD THE LET'S TALK CANNABIS
CAMPAIGN WHICH INCLUDED --
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S LEGAL
WHAT'S NOT LEGAL -- WHAT THE
PENALTIES LOOK LIKE WHAT THE
RISKS ARE FOR PREGNANT
BREASTFEEDING WOMEN AS WELL AS
YOUTH -- THIS WOULD BUILD A
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM SO THAT WE
KNOW WHAT THE IMPACTS OF
LEGALIZING CANNABIS REALLY ARE --
BRINGING TOGETHER OVER THE FIRST
COUPLE OF YEARS WE'D BE BUILDING
THAT DATA SYSTEM SO BRINGING IN
NEW DATA SOURCES MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
ANALYTIC CAPACITY TO LOOK AT
THAT DATA -- WHETHER THAT DATA
IS RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS FOR
CAN'T ABOUT US -- CORRECTIONAL
DATA HOSPITAL UTILIZATION DATA
YEAH MASS DATA BRINGING ALL OF
THAT TOGETHER SO WE COULD GET A
BETTER PICTURE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH CANNABIS AROUND
THE STATE.
OVER TIME THE AND WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THE
EDUCATION COMPONENT OF THAT
WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE TOOLS
AND INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED.
TO BE TO EDUCATE OUR YOUTH AND
OUR PARENTS ABOUT WHAT THE RISKS
ARE OF CANNABIS AND SO HAVING
THAT BETTER -- DATA CAPACITY TO
THAN TARGET OUR INTERVENTION SO
THAT WE REALLY ARE MAKING THEM
MEANINGFUL OVERTIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS A SONY PEDICLE A WE
JUST HAVE A MINOR COME IN I MEAN
THESE ARE FUNDS THAT ARE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
BECAUSE OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR BUT THAT SAID -- ONE POINT
WE WANT TO MAKE ABOUT THE DATA
IS THE DATA COLLECTION AND THE
DATA REPORTING THE DATA SYSTEMS
IS JUST THAT.
CANNABIS IS JUST ONE SUBSTANCE
OUT OF MANY SUBSTANCES THAT CAN
AFFECT YOUTH AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN.
CREATE SORT OF A COHESIVE --
DASHBOARD -- OR WAY TO ACCESS
INFORMATION TO DO COMPARATIVE
ANALYSIS -- WOULD BE QUITE
HELPFUL.
I CAN RESPOND TO THAT.
YEAH WE'RE BUILDING.
WHAT WE CALL THE ECOSYSTEM OF
DATA AND SO WE'RE USING THESE
DOLLARS FOR CANNABIS MUCH LIKE
WE'RE USING OPI DOLLARS TO START
TO BUILD THAT STATEWIDE --
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM WHEREBY WE
CAN LOOK ACROSS DISEASES --
COSTS SPECIFIC THINGS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE LEARNING HOW
THEY INTERACT WITH ONE ANOTHER
AND SO BY PULLING THOSE
INDIVIDUAL DATA ANY OF THAT
USING OUR FUNDING AS WISELY AS
POSSIBLE TO BUILD THE COMPONENTS
THAT WE NEED FOR CANNABIS.
BUT CONNECTING UP TO A HUB SO
THAT ALTHOUGH DATABASES MAY LIVE
IN OTHER PLACES WE CAN BRING ALL
OF THAT DATA INTO ONE PLACE SO
THAT ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS BENEFIT
FROM THAT INFORMATION.
DOES THE HUB ALREADY EXIST WE'RE
BUILDING THAT NOW AND WE'RE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PIECE DOLLARS
TOGETHER FROM FEDERAL OPIOID
DOLLARS WHEN WE GET DISEASE
SPECIFIC MONEY WE TRY TO BUILD
OUT.
SO THAT WE CAN BRING ALL OF THIS
TOGETHER IN THE HUB.
AND WE HAVE A ON GOING PLAN FOR
BUILDING [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE NEXT WITNESS.
OKAY LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
CHAU GIVEN THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL SURVEILLANCE IS A VITAL
COMPONENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HELPS TO INFORM A STRATEGIES TO
UTILIZE THE TYPE OF MESSAGING
THAT WE EMPLOY.
IN ORDER TO REACH TARGETED
POPULATIONS AND SO FORTH AT SOME
I LIKE IN THIS TO TOBACCO
SURVEILLANCE WHICH WE'VE BEEN
DOING FOR QUITE SOMETIME IN OVER
THE YEARS WE HAVE REALLY CHANGED
THE COURSE OF TOBACCO USE.
AND I THINK THE SAME WILL BE
TRUE FOR CANNABIS ALWAYS SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL FOR THOSE REASONS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q..
SPRING ABOUT TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD -- THE SURVEILLANCE
CAN YOU DESCRIBE THAT A LITTLE
BIT -- YEAH I'M THINKING OF
SPYING ON PEOPLE I KNOW THAT'S
NOT TRUE APPROPRIATE BUT SAYS
ENTER STAND ENSURE SYSTEM BY
SURVEILLANCE WE MEAN COLLECTING
DATA ACROSS DATA SAT SO WE WANT
TO KNOW IF THERE ARE UTILIZATION
MEDICAL UTILIZATION WE WOULD
WANT INFORMATION ABOUT THAT.
WE WOULD WANT INFORMATION ABOUT
WHERE ARE THE RETAILERS
ESTABLISHMENTS FOR CANNABIS
WHERE PEOPLE CAN PURCHASE DOES
THAT IMPACT PEOPLE THAT LIVE
AROUND THERE TO A GREATER EXTENT
AND BILL DISPARITIES INTO THE
SYSTEM.
WE WOULD WANT TO LOOK AT
CORRECTIONS DATA ARE THERE ANY
DIFFERENCES ON HOW THAT'S BEING
APPLIED ACROSS THE STATE ARE
THERE AREAS IN THE STATE THAT
ARE MOST HIGHLY IMPACTED SO THAT
WHEN WE GET.
TO PUBLIC MESSAGING AND RISK
INFORMATION THAT WE COULD TAILOR
THOSE MESSAGES USING THAT DATA
BECAUSE WITHOUT DATA WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW HOW TO TARGET OR WHAT
THE YEAH THE OTHER PIECE IS SORT
OF A AND ATTITUDES AND BELIEFS
ABOUT CANNABIS BECAUSE THE WAY
THAT WE'VE CHANGED THE CURB.
ON TOBACCO IS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T
SEE THE REST OR DIDN'T SEE SOME
OF THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE
HAVE WITH OUR NEWEST CAMPAIGN ON
TOBACCO IS AROUND JEWELS AND HE
CIGARETTES.
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE ARE
CONTAIN NICOTINE OF THOSE HAVE
THE SAME OBJECTIVE PERSON YOU
KNOW CHARACTERISTICS SO BUILDING
A SYSTEM BY WHICH WE CAN LOOK AT
THAT DATA AND THE SAME WAY WE
LOOK AT TOBACCO DATA WE CAN NOW
LOOK AT CANNABIS AND MANY OF THE
SAME WAYS.
SO WELL THEN WILL YOU BE LOOKING
OUT -- AREAS WHERE.
CULTIVATION IS A BIG PART OF THE
CULTURE OF OF CERTAIN COUNTIES
IN AREA WE'RE HOPING TO BRING
ALL THAT DATA AND ALTHOUGH THOSE
ARE REGULATED BY DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE WE WOULD HOPE TO
BRING ALL OF THAT DATA INTO ONE
PLACE SO WE CAN ALL SHARE IN THE
I AM.
THAT DATA.
BUT BECAUSE THE REASON I ASK
THIS ASSET IS THAT -- IN IN SOME
OF OUR IN IN A COUPLE OF MY
COUNTIES WE HAVE REALLY HIGH
LEVELS OF ASUS.
THAT -- AND THE ONE COMMON
FACTOR THERE IS HAS BEEN HAS
BEEN CANNABIS AND AND SO I JUST
WANT TO ASSURE THAT IF YOU'RE
DOING STE.
SURVEILLANCE THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
NOT JUST AT RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS BUT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT COMMUNITIES WERE
WHERE THIS HAS BEEN CULTIVATED
FOR MANY YEARS UNDER SECRECY
WHATEVER -- AND THAT DOESN'T
THERE THAT'S THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SIDE SURE THAT'S AND WILL
BE LOOKING AT THAT AS WELL IN
TRYING TO BUILD AS MANY OF THOSE
DATA BECAUSE PART OF WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE DATA. TO THE OTHER
GROUPS THAT ARE WORKING IN THE
REGULATORY MARKET AS WELL AND SO
WHAT WE HAVE MANUFACTURERS BUT
YOU'RE OF CANNABIS CONTROL AND
SEE IF I ALSO HAVE A ROLE IN
THAT SO BRING SOME OF THAT DATA
TOGETHER WOULD BE VERY USEFUL
[inaudible]
GIVE.
THANK GOD I JUST ADD ONE FOLLOW
UP. TO THIS QUESTION IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL SURVEY WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THE HEALTH
SURVEYS TO HAVE A REAL
UNDERSTANDING OF USAGE RATES
AMONG USE AND PERCEPTIONS OF
RISK THINGS LIKE THAT.
EXACTLY JUST FRAZIER THE KIND OF
PLAYS INTO WHAT I WAS JUST GOING
TO GO TO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PERCEPTIONS OF RISK.
THROUGH THIS DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION COMPONENT.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN THERE AND I
DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU'RE AT IS
FAR AS PER [inaudible]
BROWN'S.
BUT IS THERE ANYTHING THAT --
DESCRIBES OF HOW WHEN DRIVING
IMPAIRMENT -- PROCESS GOES
THROUGH BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF THE DRIVER'S TRAINING
ANYMORE.
IN THE SCHOOLS AND SO YOU KNOW
WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE.
LAWS THAT ARE.
ENFORCEABLE FOR DRIVING WHILE
IMPAIRED SO IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT IS IN THERE THE SHOWS.
AT THIS AGE GROUP.
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY START A A
PROCESS LIKE WE'RE WE'RE DOING
WITH BACK IN THE DAY WITH SEAT
BELTS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
ZERO SAN SO YEAH AND SO WE'RE
TRAFFIC SAFETY AND WILL BE
COLLECTING THEIR DATA AS WELL
AND WE THEY WORKED ON THE PUBLIC
CAMPAIGN WITH US AND THEN
NATIONAL THEY GOT A MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WENT.
TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO PUT
OUT SOME INFORMATION AND WE DO
INCLUDE SOME INFORMATION ON OUR
WEBSITE AS WELL ABOUT DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE NOT
NECESSARILY JUST.
THAT INFLUENCE MEANS MORE THAN
ALCOHOL.
ALL RIGHT TO IT -- IF THE TWELVE
MILLION IS FOR BOLD SURVEILLANCE
AND EDUCATION ACTIVITIES -- AND
GOING BACK TO THE THE DOCTOR
WOODS QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
IN THE SURVEILLANCE IS THAT
SOMETHING IS GOING TO BE DONE IN
THE SCHOOLS.
SOME SURVEILLANCE IT WILL
INCLUDE SCHOOL DATA ABSOLUTELY --
IT WILL BE TO THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF DATA SOURCES THAT
WILL BE COLLECTING FROM A WHOLE
VARIETY OF WHETHER IT'S
CORRECTIONS OR SCHOOLS OR WE
ALSO WILL DO SOME FORMATIVE
RESEARCH WHICH IS MORE ON THE
EDUCATION SIDE WHERE WE DO FOCUS
GROUPS AND MORE DETAILED LOOK.
AT INDIVIDUALS TO REALLY GET AT
ME A WHAT DO THEY BELIEVE HEALTH
HELP HOW DO THEY PERCEIVE RISK
AROUND.
AND CAN'T ABOUT SOME WHAT TYPES
OF CANNABIS EDIBLES VERSUS
SMOKING VERSUS OTHER USES WHICH
I NEVER KNEW HOW MANY WAYS YOU
COULD USE CANNABIS UNTIL I
STARTED I'M NOT -- AND SO REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT ARE WHAT'S
THE METHOD THAT THEY'RE SING AS
WE SAW WITH THE DEPOK OF MARKET
AS YOU RULE ONE THING OUT PEOPLE
SORT OF SEE THAT AS BAD.
THEY COME UP WITH SOMETHING NEW
AND SO ARE WE GOING TO SEE THE
OF THINGS THAT WILL BE MORE
ATTRACTIVE TO USE OVER TIME AND
HOW DO WE COMBAT THAT WITH RISK
MESSAGE AS AND SO WILL BE
COLLECTING.
THAT ATTITUDINAL SORT OF SHIFT
AND HOW DO WE GONNA BRING THAT
AROUND SO THAT WE CAN DO WHAT WE
DID WITH TO BACK.
BECAUSE TWELVE MILLION SEEMS
LIKE A LOT FOR SURVEILLANCE.
IT IT'S BOTH SURVEILLANCE AND
EDUCATION I THINK THAT WHAT WE
HAVE IN OUR BCP WHAT IS REALLY
THAT IN THE INITIAL STAGES OF
BUILDING WILL PUT MORE TOWARDS
SURVEILLANCE BUT THEN
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS WILL
BE A LOT LESS EXPENSIVE.
AND SO OF THEM WILL TURN MORE OF
THAT TO THE PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
INFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
SO I DO KNOW THAT -- WHAT IT THE
ON IN IN THE INFORMATION TWENTY
POINT TWENTY ONE MILLION?
IS FOR EDUCATION PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION -- SO I
WASN'T SURE WHAT OTHER EDUCATION
WAS INCLUDED IN THE TWELVE
MILLION SO THE TWELVE MILLION IS
A WE HAVE A COUPLE OF MILLION
BLOCKED OUT FOR ITS CONTINUING
THAT LET'S GET.
LET'S LET'S TALK CANNABIS
CAMPAIGN BASELINE REPORTING ON
WHAT WE KNOW TODAY SO IT'S
REALLY TAKING.
WHAT DATA WE HAVE TODAY MAKING
THAT INTO USABLE INFORMATION AND
THEN AS WE GET MORE AND MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION AND WE CAN
TARGET THE MESSAGES EITHER TO
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OR TWO AGE
GROUPS?
THEN WILL BE DEVELOPING BETTER
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AND AND
PUTTING MORE DOLLARS TOWARDS
GETTING THAT INTO SOCIAL MEDIA
AND DIFFERENT WAYS OF GETTING
THAT INFORMATION OUT. TO IT AND
TO REALLY HIT YOUTH WHERE THEY
WILL LEARN AND DIGEST THAT
INFORMATION VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ISSUE
NINETEEN IT'S JUST.
ALL RIGHT BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER TAYLOR
FROM THE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
OFFICE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'M SO THIS PROPOSAL AS PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S LARGER
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE RECOVERY MAY REVISION
PACKAGE.
IT'S BASED ON LESSONS LEARNED
AND DO THE INCREASE MAGNITUDE
AND FREQUENCY OF RECENT
DISASTERS.
SO THE PROPOSAL'S REQUESTING
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND SIX PERMANENT POSITIONS
TO SUPPORT HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ABOUT SHELTERS TURN
EMERGENCY AND DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY.
EFFORTS -- THE CENTER FOR HEALTH
CARE QUALITY IS REQUESTING FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND AND
GENERAL FUND AND THREE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND AND THE
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION FUND
FOR FIVE POSITIONS.
THESE POSITIONS WOULD ASSIST
FACILITIES IN DEVELOPING THEIR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS FUNDS AS
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
COULD ALSO ASSIST FACILITIES
DURING EMERGENCIES THERE'S A LOT
OF PRESSURE PUT ON FACILITIES
WHEN AN EMERGENCY HAPPENS AND
THEY HAVE TO BEGIN TO EVACUATE
PATIENTS AND FIND PLACES FOR
THOSE PATIENTS AND SO THIS.
THESE POSITIONS WOULD ASSIST
THEM WITH THAT.
IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE FOR TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN THREE SIXTY FIVE
COMMUNICATION COVERAGE FOR
EMERGENCY CALLS AND REPORTS.
OF A VINCENT DISASTERS WITH THEM
FROM AN IMPACTED HEALTH CARE
FACILITY.
AND IT WOULD PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
INFECTION CONTROL EFFORTS IN
MASS CARE SHELTERS AND
FACILITIES INCLUDING TRAINING
JUST IN TIME TRAINING FOR
VOLUNTEERS AND SHELTERS ON HOW
TO AVOID INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND
SHELTERS.
ADDITIONALLY THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS OFFICE IS ASKING
FOR A HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FOR ONE GENERAL IN
GENERAL FUND FOR ONE POSITION.
FOR AN ADDITIONAL GIS SPECIALIST --
WE HAVE -- BEEN WORKING ON
ADVANCING OUR GIS TECHNOLOGY IN
ORDER TO TRACK FOR HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES.
AND SHELTERS AND WHERE PATIENTS
ARE EVACUATED TO WE ARE ALSO
BEGINNING NOW TO INCLUDE THAT
INFORMATION FROM -- OTHER SISTER
DEPARTMENT CENTER AGENCIES FOR-DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO GIVE US A
BIGGER PICTURE OF THE IMPACT OF
DISASTERS.
AND ALL OF THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND ALL OF THE
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA THEY ARE
IMPACTED BY THOSE FACILITIES.
BY THOSE DISASTERS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
SONNY PARTICULARLY OUR OFFICES
REVIEW THIS PROPOSAL AND DOES
NOT HAVE ANY MAJOR CONCERNS AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FROM FINANCE -- DOES YOUR ANSWER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT UP PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
YES DOCTOR WOULD.
JUST CURIOUS IS -- JUST MAKE
SURE THAT THIS NONE OF THIS IS
BEING DUPLICATED FROM WHAT THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
US THIS IS YOU THIS IS UNIQUE.
YES SO THE THE UNDER THE STATE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SERVICES
AND THE NATIONAL.
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT SERVICES.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND MEDICAL THIS
IS PART OF WHAT WE'RE REQUIRED
TO DO SO IT'S THE WAY THAT.
THE METHODOLOGY SORT OF LAYS OUT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND MEDICAL
TAKES CARE OF HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND PROVIDES.
INFECTION CONTROL IN IN SHELTERS.
MEDICAL CARE AND SO THE TOTAL
WAS NINE FIFTY NINE BUT YOU SAID
AND AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT WITH NO.
BETWEEN GENERAL FUND AND AND THE
LICENSE OR CERTIFICATION FUND IT
SPLIT BETWEEN.
TWO CENTERS WITHIN CITY PH
REGENCY PREPAREDNESS OFFICE AND
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY.
OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER
NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS
.
BEGIN ONE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS STEPHANIE CLINTON AN
ACTING DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
AND FOR ISSUE TWENTY THERE'S A
TOTAL OF FIVE FIFTEEN ITEMS TO
PROVIDE UPDATES I'M ON I THINK
I'M GOING TO COVER THE FIRST
THIRTEEN AND THEN I'M MR ****
FROM APARTMENT FINANCE IS GOING
TO COVER THE LAST TWO TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS.
SO FOR THE FIRST SIX ITEMS ARE
RELATED TO OUR STATE HOSPITALS
ESTIMATE OF THE FIRST ITEM IS
THE PATIENT DRIVEN -- IN ANY
THIS IS AN UPDATE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH
WAS A REQUEST FOR TEN POINT FIVE
MILLION A BUDGET YOU'RE AN ON
GOING TO ESTABLISH A METHODOLOGY
FOR FUNDING PATIENT DRIVEN
OPERATING COSTS.
AND PROVIDE FUNDING FOR OUR
CURRENT ESTIMATED PATIENT
POPULATION MAY REVISION ADJUSTS
THE SIR ORIGINAL AMOUNT MY AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND BASED ON
UPDATED PACE PATIENT CASELOAD
ESTIMATES.
AND WE DO NOT MAKE ANY CHANGES
TO THE PROPOSED METHODOLOGY FROM
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
I THE NEXT ITEM IS THE LAND
TURMAN PETROUS SHORT POPULATION
SERVICES ADJUSTMENT A GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE HAD REQUESTED AN
INCREASED OUR REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY TO REFLECT ESTIMATED
REIMBURSEMENTS FROM THE COUNTIES
FOR THE CARE AND TREATMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE COMMITTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT THAT AS UNDER
THEIR LANCEMENT BETTER SHORT.
ACT.
WE'RE REQUESTING AN INCREASE OF
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION IN
REIMBURSEMENT TO REFLECT UPDATED
ESTIMATES FOR REIMBURSEMENTS
ESTIMATED TO BE COLLECTED AND
THEN AND BUDGET YEAR.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN SOUTH NAPA
EARTHQUAKE REPAIRS AND THIS IS
IT REFLECTS A ONE TIME SAVINGS
OF ONE POINT ONE MILLION IN
CURRENT YEAR AND SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHT THOUSAND AND BUDGET YOU'RE
ASSOCIATED WITH PROJECT THREE OF
THE NAPA EARTHQUAKE REPAIRS
PROJECTS.
AND FOLLOWING THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN NOW EARTHQUAKE THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED FUNDING TO
MAKE REPAIRS AT NAPA IN
CONJUNCTION WITH A BMI GRANT.
I WORK WAS TO BE DONE ACROSS
THREE PROJECTS AND THE THIRD
PROJECT WAS PRIMARILY COSMETIC
REPAIRS.
AND TO THE BUILDINGS THAT ARE
LOCATED WITHIN OUR SECURE
TREATMENT AREA.
DUE TO DIFFICULTY HIRING IN THE
REGION NOW DUE TO THE REBUILDING
EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING ON IN THE
REGION AFTER THE OUTLETS TUBS
FIRE -- CHALLENGES OF SWING
SPACE WITHIN OUR FACILITIES AND
THE RECENT STORMS AND REFLECTS
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCE THAT ARE
NOT DAMAGING SOME OF THE
COSMETIC REPAIRS THAT WERE
ALREADY MADE.
WE DECIDED -- TO SUPPOSED TO
DISCONTINUE THIS PROJECT -- TO
AND ALLOW US TIME TO REEVALUATE
THIS AND AS PART OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE MASTER PLANNING
EFFORTS THAT WERE CURRENTLY
UNDERWAY.
AND THEN -- DISCONTINUATION OF
THIS THIRD PROJECT WILL NOT
IMPACT PROJECTS ONE INTO WHICH
HAVE THE MORE STRUCTURAL
COMPONENTS ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE ENHANCE
TREATMENT PROGRAM STAFFING -- WE
ARE AUTHORIZED UNDER AB THIRTEEN
FORTY TO PILOT ENHANCE TREATMENT
UNITS -- TO TREAT PATIENTS ARE
AT THE HIGHEST RISK SOME
VIOLENCE AND WHO CANNOT BE
SAFELY TREATED.
IN A STANDARD TREATMENT VITAMIN
WITHIN OUR FACILITIES WE RECEIVE
FUNDING IN PRIOR YEARS FOR ABOUT
THE CONSTRUCTION AND THE
STAFFING OF FOUR UNITS A TOTAL
OF FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY NINE
BANDS.
OF THESE ARE THREE UNITS THAT
ARE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
ATASCADERO FACILITY AND AT ONE
IT D. S. H. PATTON.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ANTICIPATED A SAVINGS OF ONE
POINT SEVEN ONE MILLION SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
BUDGET YOUR FOR ESTIMATED DELAYS
FOR THE ACTIVATION OF THE ETP
UNIT AT PATTON.
AND THE MAY REVISION UPDATES AND
THE SAVINGS BY AN ADDITIONAL TWO
POINT SIX MILLION AND AND
CURRENT YEAR AND FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
AND THIS IS REFLECT UPDATED
CONSTRUCTION TIME LINES FOR ALL
OF THE ATP UNITS ALL FOUR OF
THEM.
THURMOND DELAYS DUE TO VARIOUS
CHALLENGES BUT PRIMARILY DRIVEN
BY EXISTING SITE CONDITIONS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED -- AT AT THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED AS CONSTRUCTION
GOT UNDER WAY AND REQUIRED
MITIGATION EFFORTS THAT NEED TO
BE TAKEN.
WE ALSO PROPOSED TO RE DIRECT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
IN SAVINGS TO ADDRESS THE
CRITICAL NEEDS FOR THE PATENT
ATP UNIT THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED
AS PART OF THE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT IN THESE INCLUDED.
AS THREE CHANGES A CORPORATE
SOME COURTYARD IMPROVEMENTS AND
FENCING UPGRADES AROUND THE
COURTYARD -- CONVERTING AN
EXISTING SHOWER TO A
HOUSEKEEPING CLOSET AND VERSION
OF SOME ROOMS TO CLINICAL
TREATMENT SPACES AND STAFF
OFFICES.
THE NEXT PIECE OF THIS ITEM AT A
DATE IS THE MEASURE UPON
INCREASE SEURE BED CAPACITY
PROJECT.
A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE INCLUDED
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY POSITIONS
AND TWENTY POINT ONE MILLION ON
GOING FOR UNITS FOR TWELVE AND
FOUR FOURTEEN WHICH ARE PART OF
THE METROPOLITAN ONE HUNDRED
ACTIVATION AN INCREASE OF CAN
CURE BAD PAST.
CAPACITY PROJECT WE WE SEE
FUNDING AND PRIOR BUDGET AXE FOR
THE FOR ACTIVATION OF THE FIRST
THREE UNITS.
AND ONE ALL FIVE MINUTES ARE
ACTIVATED IT'LL PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX ADDITIONAL BEDS FOR
THE TREATMENT OF FRIENDS THAT
PATIENTS -- OUT OUR FACILITIES.
PARTICULARLY THIS IS IMPORTANT
I'M TO THE DEPARTMENT IN MEETING
THE IN -- INCREASED DEMAND --
FOR PATIENTS ARE REFERRED TO AS
AS INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
AS OF THE MAY REVISION WE ARE
UPDATING THE SAVINGS AMOUNTS OF
CURRENT YEAR WERE ANTICIPATING
THREE HAVE A SAVINGS OF A THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION AND TWENTY
TWO POINT FIVE POSITIONS.
BUDGET YEAR IT'S THREE MILLION
IN TWENTY POINT ONE POSITIONS
AND THESE ARE DUE TO A
CONSTRUCTION DELAYS OF TWO
MONTHS WE'VE ADJUSTED OUT THE
TIMELINE OF EACH OF THE
ACTIVATIONS OF THE UNITS.
AND THEN FINALLY AND THERE WAS
AN ADJUSTMENT IN FISCAL YEAR --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT BEFORE OR
I'M.
A SAVINGS OF NINETEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND A HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AND THIS WAS JUST A
CORRECTION I'M WHEN THERE WAS AN
ERROR AND THOUGH I GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- THE NEXT ITEM IS THE
TELL US LIKE HIGH TREE RESOURCES.
AT ME AND THIS IS A NEW ITEM IN
MAY REVISION WE'RE PROPOSING
ELEVEN POSITIONS IN TWO POINT
TWO MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR.
TWENTY ONE POSITIONS AND THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THREE MILLION ON
GOING AND THIS IS TO INCREASE
THE USE OF TELL PSYCHIATRY TO
PROVIDE PSYCHIATRIC TREATMENT
REMOTELY TO OUR PATIENTS SAID --
COALINGA ATASCADERO IN NAPA.
AND THESE ARE THE FACILITIES
WHERE WE HAVE THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES RECRUITING
PSYCHIATRISTS.
THERE'S THREE COMPONENTS TO THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES A SENIOR
PSYCHIATRIST SUPERVISOR POSITION
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND
GUIDANCE FOR THE TELL PSYCHIATRY
PROGRAM TO TELL PSYCHIATRISTS.
EIGHTEEN PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS
TO SERVICE TELL PSYCHIATRY
COORDINATORS ON THE PATIENT AND
OF THE OF THE CONTACT.
AND THEN TO INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATE POSITIONS
AND FUNDING FOR IT EQUIPMENT IN
OFFICE FURNISHINGS THAT.
ARE NEEDED TO SUPPORT -- THIS
PROPOSAL -- THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO FILL EIGHTEEN OF OUR
PSYCHIATRIST VACANCIES ACROSS
TWO YEARS.
AS TELL PSYCHIATRISTS.
WE HAVE TWO ADJUSTMENTS AND
PROPOSED FOR CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM -- THE FIRST ONE IS AN
UPDATE TO OUR CONDITIONAL
RELEASE PROGRAM FOR SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- WE
IDENTIFIED -- SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND CURRENT
YEAR IN TWO MILLION AT TWO POINT
ONE MILLION IN BUDGET YOU'RE AN
ON GOING BASED ON AN ANTICIPATED
INCREASE IN CASE LOAD FOR
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM.
MAY REVISION REDUCING THIS
REQUEST BY ONE MILLION EACH YEAR
AND THIS IS REFLECTED UPDATED
CASELOAD OF EIGHTEEN SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR CLIENTS IN
CONROE UP BY THE END OF CURRENT
YEAR.
IN AN ADDITIONAL THREE SB PIECE
TO BE RELEASED AND BUDGET YEAR
FOR A TOTAL OF TWENTY ONE OF
CLIENTS AND CONRAD BY THE AT THE
END OF NEXT -- BUT AT THE END
BUDGET HERE.
AT THE SECOND PIECE OF OUR A
CONTRACT UPDATE IS FORCED TO
STEP DOWN TRANSITION PROGRAM --
THIS IS A NEW ITEM FROM A
REVISION IT WE'RE REQUESTING
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR AN ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION ON GOING.
AND THIS IS TO CONTRACT FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT BED VENDOR
OPERATED COMMUNITY STEP DOWN
PROGRAM.
IN THIS WILL SERVE ME MENTALLY
DISORDERED OFFENDERS AND NOT
GUILTY BY REASON OF INSANITY
PATIENTS WERE PREPARING.
FOR CONDITIONAL RELEASE FROM THE
STATE HOSPITALS IN AND OUT TO
THE COMMUNITY WITHIN ABOUT
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
THIS IS SOOM START P ACTIVITIES
OF ABOUT SEVEN TO NINE MONTHS
WHICH INCLUDES SOME PHYSICAL
SPACE MODIFICATIONS AT THE
FACILITY TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY FOR THE PATIENTS --
THAT'S ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THE FUNDING AND IT
SEEMS ACTIVATION OF THE BED
STARTING IN FEBRUARY SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FEBRUARY AND APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS TO FULLY FILL THOSE BANDS.
THIS ALSO INCLUDES EXPANDING OUR
CURRENT -- EXISTING CONTRACT
WITH SOMEWHERE HEALTH AND
REHABILITATION CENTER BY FOR
MEN'S -- FOR MAKING IT A TOTAL
OF TWENTY FOUR BEDS AT THAT
FACILITY THIS EXISTING PROGRAM
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR NOT GUILTY
BY REASON OF INSANITY
COMMITMENTS OR IMMINENTLY READY
FOR TRANSITION TO CONRAD.
AND FOR IN JACK CLIENTS WHO ARE
OUT AND CONRAD WHO MAY NEED A
HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICE AND IN
THE KEEP IT YOU LAWS AS TO
TRANSITION THEM BACK INTO THAT
PROGRAM OTHER THAN GOING ALL THE
WAY BACK UP TO A STATE HOSPITAL
BED.
THE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM
EXPANSION IS TO HELP PATIENTS
PREPARE FOR SUCCESSFUL I'M
TRANSITION INTO THE COMMUNITY BY
TRANSFERRING THEM TO OUR LOWER
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
AND THEN TO FOCUS ON THE SKILLS
THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR MORE
INDEPENDENT LIVING ENVIRONMENT
WHEN THEY TRANSITION TO CONRAD.
AND FINALLY IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
US THE TO BACK FILL THE STATE
HOSPITAL BEDS WITH -- WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PENDING PLACEMENT ON FROM OUR
WAITLIST.
I WE ALSO HAVE IMAGES MONTHS
PROPOSED FOR JOE MAYS COMPETENCY
TREATMENT PROGRAM VERSUS FOR
EXISTING PROGRAM.
THIS IS A PROPOSED COSTS
DECREASE AND GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WIDE WE IDENTIFIED SAVINGS IN
CURRENT YEAR OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND AND PROPOSE
ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION. ONE
POINT ONE MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR
AND ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION ON
GOING TO SUPPORT COST INCREASES
FOR ITS EXISTING PART PART
EXISTING PROGRAMS.
ANIME REVISION WE INCREASE THE
CURRENT YOUR SAVINGS BY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND AND REDUCE THE BUDGET
YOU'RE AN ONGOING REQUEST BY.
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND DUE
TO ACTIVATION DELAYS AND CHANGES
PROGRAM CAPACITY FOR FIVE OF OUR
PROGRAMS.
IS BEING OUR CINEMA G. B. C. T.
THE MENDOCINO JAIL BASS
COMPENSATE TREATMENT PROGRAM
MONTEREY PROGRAM THE SAN JOAQUIN
PROGRAM AND STANISLAUS PROGRAM --
THE OF BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
PROPOSAL AND TO ADJUST OUR NEW
PROGRAM PROPOSAL FROM GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REDUCING THE REQUEST BY
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE BY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THIS IS
BASED ON THE CURRENT DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE A PROPOSED PROGRAMS AND
THE CONTRACT NEGOTIATION SO THIS
IS JUST UPDATING THE CURRENT
ESTIMATED TIME LINES FOR THOSE
ACTIVATIONS.
APPARENTLY WE HAVE THE TO
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS AND I'LL
TURN NOT EVER TO STIR.
HAN WINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
ADJUSTMENTS THAT TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS ALSO INCLUDED IN THE
MAY REVISION -- AND ALTHOUGH THE
FIRST -- ONE THE FIRST ONE IS
THE TO TRANSFER OF FUNDING -- TO
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS TO THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
AND THERE'S A DUE TO
HISTORICALLY THE ONE POSITIONS
WITHIN THEIR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY WAS FUNDED.
BY THE STATE HOSPITAL BUDGETS.
AND SO THIS I REQUEST WOULD PROP
MORE PROPERLY ALIGNED THE THE
FUNDING SOURCE WITH THE POSITION
AUTHORITY AND UNDER THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
AND THE SECOND A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT IS THAT THE STATE
LOTTERY EDUCATION FUND AND
ANNUALLY -- THEY ADJUST THE
REVENUE DISBURSEMENT TO THE
PUBLIC AGENCIES WHICH STATE
HOSPITAL HAS A PIECE OF IT AND
THIS -- I REQUEST AS TO INCREASE
THE THE AUTHORITY BY A SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
VERY GOOD NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
TONY PARTICULARLY -- WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THESE
PROPOSALS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU DON'T NORMALLY SEE ANYTHING
IN OUR INFORMATION ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
JUST A LITTLE UNUSUAL AND FROM
THE LOTTERY.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON TYLER
IN THE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRACTORS SO
STATION OF CALIFORNIA -- WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE USE OF
TELL US AYE CATCHER WITHIN THE
STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM -- WE
BELIEVE THAT IS AN IMPORTANT NON
USE TO HOP ON THE EXPAND THE USE
OF TELL US AYE KAIJU THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- ESPECIALLY IN THE
LIGHT OF A SHORTAGE OF ON MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AS WE DID
HERE EARLIER TODAY IN THE WET
FUNDING PROPOSAL -- WE ARE ALSO
ADDITIONALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXPANSION OF THE USE OF CONRAD
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM.
AND TO SUPPORT -- AND EFFECTIVE
ON CONTINUITY OF CARE AND THEN A
STEP DOWN BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
YES DOCTOR WOULD.
WHEN DID YOU TESTIFY BEFORE US
BEFORE?
IN MARCH MARCH.
THE REASON I ASK LOOK I I DON'T
HAVE OBJECTION TO THE WHAT'S
COMING FORWARD FOR PROPOSALS.
BUT SOME IS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT --
THE KH REP FOR EXAMPLE IS IS
IS SIGNIFICANT SOAP THAT TELLS
ME YOU GUYS BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THIS FOR A WHILE SO DID YOU JUST.
I DON'T RECALL I WASN'T I DON'T
RECALL YOUR TESTIFIED SO I MAY
NOT BEEN HERE.
DID YOU GIVE US ANY SORT OF
HEADS UP THAT THESE THINGS MIGHT
BE COMING DOWN THE LINE.
AS THE TWO NEW PROPOSALS THAT
WERE IN AND THIS PROPOSAL WAS
THE AND THE CONDITIONAL REALLY
STEP DOWN PROGRAM.
AND THE TELL US I KINDA TREE
PROPOSAL AND NO THOSE ITEMS WERE
NOT -- FORECASTED IN THAT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- BUT IT
PROPOSALS THAT WE WERE STILL
WORKING AND IDENTIFYING A VENDOR
AT THE TIME.
I GUESS FROM A PERSPECTIVE MEAN
THEIR SIGNIFICANT EXPENDITURES
THEY'RE THEY'RE WORTH WHILE I
MEAN DON'T GET ME WRONG THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT EXPENDITURES BUT
I WOULD I WOULD JUST SAY IN
GENERAL WILL BE KINDA NICE. TO
LET US KNOW THAT THE SOME OF
THESE MIGHT BE COMING THEIR
SIGNIFICANT WHILE THE GOVERNOR
IS OFFERING A LOT OF A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF OTHER THINGS THAT
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS.
HAS A DESIRE TO SEE FUNDED --
THEY DIDN'T SHOW UP IN THE MAY
REVISE AND SO WILL BE KIND OF
NICE TO KNOW IN THE FUTURE THIS.
MESSAGE IS FOR YOU BUT AS A
MESSAGE TO THE WORLD LIVING
LISTENING OUT THERE.
THAT IF THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
THINGS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THIS IS LESSEN ITS TWO MONTHS
SINCE YOU TESTIFIED BEFORE
THAT'S WHY I BROUGHT IT UP.
CLEARLY A PROPOSAL THE CONTRACT
FOR SEVENTY EIGHT BED --
FACILITY DOESN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT -- CLEARLY THE THOUGHT
ABOUT TELL PSYCHIATRY DOESN'T
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
IT WOULD JUST BE NICE THAT WE
AND WE HAD A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
A HEADS UP GOING FORWARD -- LIKE
I SAID WE HAVE AS A COMMITTEE WE
HAVE THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AS WELL AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE.
BUT IN OUR PLANNING PROCESS IT
WOULD BE NICE TO KNOW THAT THEIR
SIGNIFICANT EXPENDITURES LIKE
THIS COMING FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR SHOULD BE BACK
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
I CONCLUDES ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY ALL RIGHT ISSUE.
TWENTY ONE IN THIS ITEM IS A
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
LARGER DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY PACKAGE --
THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING SIX
POSITIONS AND NINE HUNDRED
NINETY SIX THOUSAND IN FISCAL
YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY AND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
ON GOING TO SUPPORT OUR NEED FOR
AND TO STRENGTHEN THE EMERGENCY
PART AS A RESPONSE EFFORTS AT
THE DEPARTMENT.
AS A RESULT OF THE LESSONS THAT
WE LEARNED THROUGH THE OCTOBER
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN ATLUS
TUBS FIRES ON THAT THREATENED
NAPA STATE HOSPITAL AND WE HAD A
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO TEST OUR
EMERGENCY PLANNING AND RESPONSE
AND AND FROM THAT EVENT WE WERE
ABLE TO AND IT.
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF LESSONS
LEARNED IN THIS PROPOSAL AS IT
SEEKS TO SHORE UP SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES THAT WE SAW DURING
THAT -- DURING THAT EVENT AS SO
WE'RE REQUESTING FUNDING.
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
UNNECESSARY SYSTEMS FOR EMPLOYEE
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION.
TEMPORARY MOBILE DISASTER
OPERATIONAL FACILITIES FOR
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTERS INCREASE ACCESS TO
SATELLITE EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION -- PHONES --
CREATING INTEGRATED
COMPREHENSIVE INTO EFFECTIVE
BUSINESS CONTINUITY PLANS
TRAININGS AND EXERCISES AND THEN
DESIGNATING SPECIFIC PERSON NOW
AND TO MANAGE THE COMPLIANCE
WITH REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
AND COORDINATE THE RESPONSE
MITIGATION IMPATIENT MOVEMENT
AND RECOVERY IN EVENT.
OF AN ACTUAL EMERGENCY AND
THAT'S THE A SIX POSITIONS THAT
WERE REQUESTING BY ABOUT EACH OF
OUR HOSPITALS AND ONE FOR A IN
IN HEADQUARTERS TO SERVICE THE
COORDINATOR.
SAY MY CORD INTER.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
SENATE PARTICULARLY -- NO
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
OR FINANCE NO CON.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
OF A PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SAYING NONE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON ISSUE.
TWENTY ONE MOVING ON TO ISSUE.
TWENTY TWO GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS GEORGE MAYNARD.
I'M THE ADMIN SERVICES DEPUTY
FOR THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
HOSPITALS.
AND TODAY I COME BEFORE YOU WITH --
PROPOSAL.
FOR THE RELOCATION OF THREE
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP YOU MISS
SERVICE AGENCY DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENTS STATE HOSPITAL. TO
THE CLIFFORD L. ALLENBY BUILDING.
AND THE MAY RISE MAY REVISE
SPECIFICALLY REQUEST EIGHT POINT
THREE MILLION -- TO AFFECT THE
PHASE ONE IMPROVEMENTS AND THE
THE PROJECT COSTS TO PREPARE THE
BUILDING AS A CONSTRUCTION IS
COMPLETED.
AND PREPARE FOR THE ACTUAL MOVE
IN IN -- TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION -- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND THREE POINT FOUR MILLION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES THE
MIGRATION OF ALL OF THE
NECESSARY IT INFRASTRUCTURE
EQUIPMENT -- THAT CAN BE USED --
NEW EQUIPMENT WHERE NECESSARY --
TO BASICALLY INSTALL AT A SHARE
NETWORK SERVICES ACROSS THE FOR
ALL THREE AGENCIES AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT REDUCING.
ENERGY REDUCE OR THE ENERGY
COSTS BY ABOUT 75% BY SHARING
THE EQUIPMENT AND COMBINING
SERVICES ON THOSE.
AND AS A NEW BUILDING THE
BUILDING IS IS SUSCEPTIBLE TO
ALL THE NEW TGS STANDARDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S GUIDELINES FOR LOW
EFFICIENCY.
SO MANY OF THE IMPROVEMENTS IN
THE BUILDING A RELATED TO THAT
AND REDUCTIONS OF BOTH THE
ELECTRICAL USE UTILITY LOSE USE.
AND ALSO IN THE CASE OF
ELECTRONIC DOCUMENT MANAGEMENT
PROPOSAL IN HERE IS A REDUCTION
OF RECORDS -- WE CURRENTLY HAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION PAPER RECORDS IN THE
CURRENT BUILDING.
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES THE PROPOSAL FOR
ELECTRONIC DOCUMENT MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO BOTH -- WORK
THROUGH A PURGING PROGRAM AND
THEN A SCANNING AND RECORD
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE INTO THE BUILDING AND HAVE
READY IN DIRECT ACCESS TO THOSE
CRITICAL -- RECORDS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN OUR
BUSINESS FUNCTION -- AT THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
FOR NEXT WITH A CONTRACT FOR THE
SCANNING STORAGE IN THE RECORDS
MANAGEMENT SERVICES -- PRIOR TO
THE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MOVE IN DATE.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
SONYA PICK LA -- A YOU MAY
RECALL THAT THIS SIMILAR ISSUE
CAME UP YESTERDAY AND THE
HEARING ON DDS AND WE JUST HAVE
A MINOR POINT ABOUT THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE SO THAT THE
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
CONCERNS TO THE SCANNING
ARCHIVAL AND DESTRUCTION OF
DOCUMENTS -- BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
WOULD PREFER NOT TO WORK WITH
DDS TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES
BECAUSE IT WOULD COST -- ROUGHLY
TWICE AS MUCH -- SO THE
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
EXEMPTS THEM FROM WORKING WITH
DDS BUT IT ALSO EXEMPTS THEM
CODE -- OUR OFFICE RECOMMENDS
EXEMPTING THEM ONLY FROM WORKING
WITH TGS AND NOT FROM -- THE END
STILL HAVING TO FOLLOW THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE AND IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH OUR OFFICE
TO REVISE THE LANGUAGE TO
REFLECT THAT.
THANK YOU AND THAT IS ACCURATE I
THINK THAT'S A VERY FAIR REQUEST
AND I THINK MOST APPROPRIATE IN
THIS.
A HIGH ONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND AND THE RETURN THE REASON
BEHIND THIS A LANGUAGES --
BASICALLY TO ACHIEVE THAT TIME
THE AND YOU FISH AND PROCUREMENT
PROCESS AS WELL AS THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS.
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE LA -- ON REFINING
THIS LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
CAN TO TAKE YOU OUT OF ORDER
THERE -- LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible] TO FRAZIER.
SO THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR FOR
MANY MANY YEARS IN MY PRIVATE
LIFE.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE ALEJO'S
CONSIDERATION I'VE SEEN --
PROJECTS THE TGS OF HAVE RUN UP
ON TRUCKS FOR MERRY AMOUNTS.
OF CIRCUMVENTING THE OTHER
COMPONENT WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY.
NOT WORTH THE EXPEDIENCY -- WHEN
WE LOOK AT?
BEING FAIR AND PUTTING IT OUT TO
BID IN A PROPER FASHION -- I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ELLIE HE DE COMPONENT OF THIS --
SOMETIMES YOU SPEND TOO MUCH TO
GAIN VERY LITTLE AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PROCESS.
IS A BEST VALUE FOR THE PEOPLE
AND NOT JUST A CERTIFICATION.
SO I'D LOVE TO SEE THE BIDS
COMING BACK.
ALSO THAT I I CAN ACTUALLY
REVIEW AND ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT.
JUST BECAUSE HE ONE L. E. D..
IN AN OLDER BUILDING. TO TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT AND GET THE
CERTIFICATION MAY NOT BE WORTH.
THE THE EXPENDITURE SO I HOPE
THAT WE LOOK AT THAT PROCESS
GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
ALL RIGHT SINGLE FOR THE
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE HI THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ON ISSUE.
TWENTY TWO AND NOW FOR THE LAST --
DISCUSSION ITEM ISSUE.
TWENTY THREE AND THAT WILL BE ME
AGAIN SO ISSUE WELCOME BACK
THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY THREE IS FOR
STATEWIDE ENHANCE TREATMENT
PROGRAM CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSAL.
AND THE CURRENT REQUEST IN MAY
REVISE IS FOR TWO POINT THREE
EIGHT SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
INCREASE COSTS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE
STATEWIDE ENHANCE TREATMENT
PROGRAM -- CURRENTLY WITH TO
PLANNED IN HAND STROKE --
TREATMENT PROGRAMS CURRENT OFTEN
KNOWN AS ATP'S CONSTRUCTION IS
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY TO TASK AT
OUR STATE HOSPITAL -- WE ARE
LOOKING AT THREE UNITS TO BE
COMPLETED THIRTY NINE BEDS FOR
MALE PATIENTS AND THAT'S ABOUT
25230% COMPLETE -- THESE COSTS
ARE TO ADDRESS THE INCREASING
CONSTRUCTION COSTS FOR THE D. S.
H. PATTON -- CONSTRUCTION WHICH
IS STILL TO BE STARTED AND THAT
WILL BE THE TEN BED UNIT FOR
FEMALES FOR STATEWIDE -- YOU SIR
FOR THE FEMALE POPULATION --
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO THE INCREASE
COSTS WERE -- SOME
UNDERESTIMATION AT THE INITIAL.
PROJECT COSTING FOR THE FIRE
SPRINKLER SYSTEM IN IT INTO AN
OCCUPIED BUILDING -- AS OPPOSED
TO NOT AN OCCUPIED BUILDING IN
THE LABOR COSTS AND THINGS THAT
ARE DONE THERE -- FOR PATIENT
MOVEMENT -- ADDITIONAL COST OF
PROCUREMENT OF THE DETENTION
STYLE DOORS WHICH ARE QUITE
EXPENSIVE -- BUT USED IN THIS
TYPE OF FACILITY FOR THIS
LICENSE -- WE DID HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF BIDDERS ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT AND THEN --
THEY JUST WANT OF LABOR COSTS --
ALSO WERE HIGHER THE IN
CONSIDERING THE WORKING IN THIS
SECURE TREATMENT ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THERE'S A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF STAFF -- BRINGING
TOOLS AND AN OUT VERY STRICT
TOOL CONTROL WEAPONS -- TOO SURE
NO WEAPONS OR CONTRABAND COME
INTO THE PATIENT'S CARE.
SO THE TOTAL PROJECT COST FOR
THESE TWO PROGRAMS AT ATASCADERO
PATTON IS APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN
MILLION AND THIS WOULD THIS TWO
POINT THREE SEVEN MILLION IS
DESIGNED TO COMPLETE THE
CONSTRUCTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
A NO COMMENT FROM LA -- THANK
YOU.
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT FINANCE
THANK YOU LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
I DO KNOW THAT -- MY COLLEAGUES
JAMES WRONG ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JAMES FROM US -- IT IS HIS
DISTRICT THAT HAS PATTON STATE
HOSPITAL AND I KNOW THAT HE
APPRECIATES ALL THE THE WORK.
THAT IS BEING DONE THERE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK IS BEING
DONE AT PENN STATE HOSPITAL IN
THE INCREASE.
IN THE FUNDING THAT CONTINUES --
TO GOING TO PENN STATE HOSPITAL.
WE'VE SEEN IT -- IN THE
TRANSPIRES -- INTO THE AREA AS
FAR AS JOBS AND THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT ARE THERE -- AND IT
IS A CENTER POINT FOR OUR
DISTRICTS I DEEPLY DO APPRECIATE
THAT AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
CHAIR OF WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
ON THOSE BEHALF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT --
THAT CONCLUDES ALL OF THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS.
ITEMS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE OR
NON DISCUSSION ITEMS IS OR
ANYBODY IN THE PUBLIC THAT
WISHES TO DISCUSS.
ARE THERE THOSE.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY JUST HERE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT UNDER ITEM
TWENTY FOUR FOR THE HEALTH HOME
PROGRAM TRAILER BILL EXTENSION
THAT JUST THE LINES WITH THE
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL
AS WITH THE UNDER ITEM -- TWO
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE ON THE HOME
VISITING AND BLACK INFANT HOME
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SAYING NOTHING FURTHER FROM THE
PUBLIC OR FROM THE DíAS.
THIS CONCLUDES.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
ONE OF THE STATE